welcome to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast in today's
episode Greg is forced to issue a formal
apology for its previous missteps
followed by an impressive batch of new
feats of strength then we discussed
plenty of new research related to
fructose ingestion nice leaves and a
variety of factors that may make weight
loss harder or easier for certain
individuals to close out the episode
we've got a fantastic interview with
James Krieger in the interview we talked
about the insulin hypothesis
non-exercise activity thermogenesis why
you should or shouldn't measure your
body composition and much more as always
thank you for listening and enjoy the
show welcome back to the stronger by
science podcast this is your host eric
Trexler and today and potentially for
today only I am joined by a very
temporary guest host named Greg knuckles
thanks for finding it in your heart to
bring me back it I did a lot of
soul-searching I did a lot of thinking a
lot of talking with my legal team and we
figured it was best to give you one more
shot before we get into the fitness
content a huge scandal very you know
enormous controversy brewing we are
getting roasted on our reviews largely
due to some errors in judgment on your
part so I want to give you the
opportunity to speak to the public and
to make things right yeah so there have
been some pretty scathing itunes reviews
after our last few episodes mainly
focused around my conservative family
centric etc worldview and our mutual
views on marijuana and whether or not it
should be legal hint it shouldn't so
here's what some people have had to say
on our iTunes reviews so direct quote
came for some solid science but in the
first 10 minutes they went full of the
government knows best on marijuana laws
parentheses in spite of co-hosts being a
fan of craft beers remember prohibition
closed parenthesis and followed it with
we're a Christian nation and if you
don't love Jesus get out I will say
that's actually a misquote just to stick
up for myself I said something similar
but not
exactly that I don't remember well that
that's a strong defense Greg got'em type
comment thanks for getting the BS out
early I guess I only wasted ten minutes
won't ever read or listen again so cool
someone else said honestly I love the
science-based values you guys provide
however on the latest rant about the
cannabis issue and the whole [ __ ]
Christian views we had to unsubscribe
with one star would have thought
science-based individuals would use
critical thinking about Christianity and
government a bit better nope both of you
are pretty reformed I think that's
supposed to be uninformed are both
pretty reformed and ignorant to the two
entities that actually control the mass
I assume that's masses one being
government the other used as a tool for
restraint and finally if I could
interject if they're suggesting that I
think they're talking about mass the
monthly research review I think they're
suggesting that we we are just kind of
more up it's or maybe masked the thing
which one would cultivate I don't know I
mean there's a there's multiple layers
to that review I think this person
saying that we need more government and
religion to get big problem I mean we
recently ran the episode with Ben
[ __ ] talking about the roots of
physical culture in the West being
muscular Christianity mm-hmm maybe this
guy's just a physical culture enthusiast
might be anyway last review short and
sweet weed is one thing but statement if
you have a problem with the laws of this
country you have a problem with Jesus
that's actually what I said so this
reminded me I didn't say if you don't
love Jesus get out I said if you have a
problem with the laws you have a problem
with Jesus
get out may have been implied but it
wasn't directly stated yeah
anyway this person says that statement
is ignorant and culturally incompetent
so just to address all of this I could
get defensive and I feel like I would be
very much within my rights to do so
because this is yet another example of
conservative opinions being censored you
may say well Craig that's not exactly
censorship
you still have a podcast that you're
putting out to tend the tens of
thousands of people but I would say it's
essentially censorship because people
are publicly disagreeing with me which
is essentially censorship and I think
might be a violation of my First
Amendment rights is definitely
unconstitutional right so yeah I mean I
could get defensive I'd be very much
within my rights to do so but I will be
a bigger person and read a statement I
want to be clear I'm not admitting fault
I was advised by my lawyers to not do so
because the forces of evil in this
country might try to further silence my
conservative viewpoints but anyway
here's my statement which I hope will
clear everything up here goes I am not
at all sorry about what I said
but I regret if if it hurt anyone's
feelings so I hope that clears the air
and we we should be good right I think I
think we should be good
I just don't know what it's gonna take
reg the sarcasm is baked into the cake
with this show so but not in that last
side no no no no no no no no no
definitely not okay so another thing
that is a permanent fixture of this show
is feats of strength so very very long
list of feats of strength here a lot of
people doing a lot of strong things so I
actually abbreviated it pretty
substantially IPF single-ply world's was
took place recently and I think eight
World Records got broken in the total
I'm not going to read all of those but I
am going to talk about one weight class
and a little bit of powerlifting history
well that's going to come last to start
with though the super heavyweight
untested with wraps total was broken
recently that sounds like a lot of
qualifiers but I think that's one of
like probably the most prestigious
records out there right now just because
like most unten
raw powerlifting is done with wraps
these days super heavyweights lift the
biggest weights pretty cool
Milana czev has ruled that class since a
long time ago I want to say maybe 2013
2012 really once Rawls started becoming
really popular again he kind of took
over that class and has maintained
basically a stranglehold on it but
Daniel Bell recently broke his world
record with almost an identical
performance to Milano Jeff's best so
Daniel Bell went 42 and a half kilos in
the squat that's a thousand 63 260 kilos
in the bench that's 573 and 400 kilos in
the deadlift which is 881 for a total of
eleven hundred forty two and a half
kilos or 25 hundred and eighteen point
seven pounds like I said that was a
nearly identical performance to Milano
Jeff Milano Jeff squatted two and a half
kilos more but Daniel Bell benched five
kilos more so he be this total by two
and a half kilos with an identical
deadlift regarding the deadlift it was
somewhat sketchy and so I've seen some
level of controversy about the
performance to my eye it looked like he
locked out his deadlift and then like
his grip started slipping so the bars
started getting lowered and it looked
like he got the down command before that
started happening and I mean you know
the rule is you have to lock it out and
get the down command so it wasn't it
wasn't a picture-perfect deadlift but I
mean to my eye he got it up looked like
he got a full lockout I'm personally
happy with it people are entitled to
their own opinions not when it comes to
marijuana but when it comes to two lifts
another very prestigious super
heavyweight record was broken recently
that's the IPF single ply world record
Blaine Sumner has done it again he is
basically the god of single ply super
heavy weight lifting broke his own world
record which he previously set back in
2017 squatted for 90
five kilos which is a little bit over a
thousand and ninety one pounds he
benched for 25 and a half kilos which is
938 he has previously benched more in a
bench only meat but I think that might
be the heaviest full meat single-ply
bench ever and he dead lifted 355 kilos
which is 782 pounds for a total of 12 75
and a half or 28 12 so that's obviously
super impressive he's still the only
person to ever total 2800 at single-ply
he's now done it twice no one else has
ever done it he is an absolute beast in
that class and then so moving on from
competition to Instagram which might be
what really matters one of my Instagram
followers sent me a video which the lift
itself was impressive and then I saw how
much the guy weighed and it became
stupidly impressive so a Turkish guide
muhammad IE ce ra ESI it was a video of
him squatting 380 kilos which is 837
pounds the lift itself was a little
sketchy it looked a little bit high in
the spotter touched the bar slightly
through the sticking point it looked
like it was gonna go up anyways but like
crazy heavy squat a little bit sketchy
his previous video was a really clean
365 kilo squat which is 805 clean look
to be convincingly to depth then I saw
how much the guy weighed and he competes
in the 82 and a half kilo class which is
181 and the current world record in that
class is 788 by Tom calles set I believe
in March of this year and so like both
of those lifts would break the world
record the kids only 22 years old I
believe and I looked him up on open
powerlifting and he only has one meet in
the archive
I think he may have competed more but
open powerlifting may not have them in
their archive yet but he only has one
recorded meet on there and he squatted
738 and a half or three hundred 35 kilos
earlier this year I think in in like
August or something so I mean he looks
clearly good for 800 and maybe
comfortably over 800 and seems to be
improving very very quickly so another
recent video of his he was dead lifting
325 kilos got it cleanly his best in a
meet I think is 295 so this is a kid to
look to look out for like I said he's
young I think he's he's only 22 he
currently has the number 11 squat in a
meet in that weight class looks like
he's gonna break the world record at
some point and seems to be improving
very very rapidly so Muhammad Ryu see -
a guy - to look out for and then the the
news story I would say from the IPF
single-ply World Championships is that
KL beckylyn won the 74 kilo class the
reason that is news is because of the
person he beat so he beat Yaroslav Olek
and that is amazing so Backlund was has
been competitive the last couple of
years but hasn't been able to topple
Olek
Olek is like 44 or 45 years old he hit
his best total at 42 years old a couple
years ago only guy - total over 2000
pounds in that weight class totaled 908
kilos which is like 2001 pounds or
something like that
but he like he seems to finally be
showing some effects of aging his totals
the last couple of years have been a
little bit lower but this is the first
time he's lost a full meet since 2001
and by lost I mean he got silver he I
think also got silver at the world
benchpress championships in like 2009
but he won
the open class for 17 years straight
from 2002 until 2018 and he did that in
some of the most competitive weight
classes in the sport so between the 67
and a half kilo class in that 83 kilo
class he's also a three-time World Games
champion and that's even more impressive
because Olek like pretty much his entire
career after about 2006 he has been in
the 75 and now 74 kilo weight class he
was 67 and a half before that the world
games doesn't have as many weight
classes as like a normal powerlifting
meet would and so the middle weight
class for the World Games was eighty two
and a half and now more recently 83 at
those meets he's still weighed in as if
he was going to compete at 75 or 74 so
he was giving up 10 kilos to people
who's competing against and still won
three times in a row
adding to the 17 straight World
Championship so that's essentially 20
World Championships in a span of 17
years which I mean in my opinion makes
him the greatest IPF lifter of all time
and at least in terms of sustained
success maybe the best power lifter of
all time the two other people who would
generally come up in that conversation
are Lamar Gant who won 15 times in a row
in the 56 and 60 kilo classes and Hideki
Inaba who won 17 times in a row in the
52 kilo class the reason that so like
those guys are obviously absolute
legends I think a lot of people know
about Lamar can't because of his
ridiculous deadlift exploits in
lightweight classes also a very
underrated all-around power lifter he
had one point held all three individual
records squat bench and deadlift in the
weight classes he competed in but most
well known for his just absolutely
insane deadlifts with absolutely gnarly
scoliosis if you've never seen a video
of Lamar Gant deadlift you owe it to
yourself you should look it up
but he's someone who often gets brought
up in this conversation for winning 15
times in a row and Inaba previously held
the record for 17 World Championships
Olek tied that he didn't beat it since
Backlund beat him this year even though
he may come back and win next year who's
to say but in my opinion elects
accomplishments are a little bit more
impressive because one powerlifting is
just a way way bigger sport now than it
was then it's I mean I don't know the
numbers right off the top of my head
comparing current numbers in the sport
to the early 80s but I feel like there
have to be at least 5 or 10 fold more
people in the sport so he's competing
against a deeper talent pool and he also
did it in more competitive weight
classes like Inaba was absolutely
impressive I think his best total in the
52 kilo class is still like top 3 or top
five all-time which is awesome but there
also aren't that many full grown adult
males who weigh 52 kilos that's 114
pounds the 67 and a half kilo class the
70 the 75 kilo class now the 74 kilo
class those are all really competitive
especially the 75 and 74 so Olek won 17
times straight against you know a deeper
talent pool and in a more competitive
weight class so not to take anything
away from those other guys but in my
opinion Olek is probably the best single
ply lifter ever at least in terms of
sustained success and the reason I'm
going on and on about this so much is I
feel like he doesn't have the name
recognition and respect that he deserves
like when when the goat conversation
comes up you'll often hear Gant and
Inaba come up you'll often hear at Kohn
mentioned there there are several other
people who may come up in that
conversation if it is bandied about you
very very rarely hear anyone bring up
Olek which i think is absurd like his
body of work speaks for itself and so
you know I'm sure he'll be back
but congrats to him for a great career
so far and congrats to Backlund for
being the first person since 2001 to
take him down okay so I've got a new
segment could be a one-time segment I
don't know but I'm calling it hot off
the press the reason I'm calling it that
I saw a study that was published online
yesterday that is a bit relevant it's
it's a question that I get a lot I'm not
gonna do a really deep dive on the study
but it is one of those things where I
saw it come up and figure good hey I
know several thousand people that would
like to hear about this so the paper was
called metabolic effects of a prolonged
very high dose dietary fructose
challenge in healthy subjects and it was
published by magis at all and like I
said it was published yesterday now the
purpose of the study here was to
investigate basically what happens when
we give healthy people really high doses
of fructose for a sustained kind of
prolonged period of time so they got 10
healthy subjects they were 28 years old
on average but a big range it was 28
plus or minus 19 that's a pretty huge
variability there and you know that
skews up yeah yeah as it because it's
not like they have that many 11
year-olds yeah exactly
BMI on average was 22 and what they did
was they gave him for an eight-week
protocol they gave him a hundred and
fifty grams per day of fructose that's a
lot of fructose and the reason I wanted
to kind of quickly report these findings
is because I have a lot of people who
who will ask me hey I really like fruit
but I'm reading on the internet that
fructose which is a you know one of the
predominant types of sugar in fruit
that's a misconception by the way a lot
of people think that all of the sugar in
fruit is fructose and that's not the
case but but it is a fruit is a big
source of fructose in the diet I think
that's because then a lot of well I may
be about to talk out of my ass I was
going to say in a lot of introductory
nutrition classes you learn that
fructose is fruit sugar right I don't
know if that's taught in a lot of
classes that's what was taught in my
introductory nutrition class no yeah I
assume
that's a somewhat common thing yeah
people think of fructose and they say oh
that's the sugar from fruit and I mean
table sugar and high fructose corn syrup
and like well table sugars 5050 right
sucrose that's yeah it's half glucose
and fructose so we get it all over the
place but people kind of connect it in
their mind to fruit and then by
extension they think all fruit sugar is
fructose and that's not the case it's
actually a mixture of multiple simple
sugars but in any case 150 grams daily
like I said I get a lot of people who
say Eric I like fruit I don't know
anybody that likes fruit this much that
they're getting a hundred and fifty
daily grams of fructose from their fruit
intake unless like durianrider or
freelee the banana girl are listening to
us exactly yeah I mean so what's up yeah
I'd love to have you know but so could
you do it sure but the question would be
why you know so in any case what I
really like about this is you know it's
a controlled intervention where they
really are pushing pretty much the
higher limit that you would even
consider like feasibly obtaining in a
diet unless you're trying to prove a
point
basically what they found like I said it
was an eight-week intervention the
people who they gave them this high
fructose intake what they did was that
they saw that there was lower intake of
other dietary sugars to kind of
compensate for that not intentionally
but it's just kind of what happened and
they did not really increase their total
daily energy intake in response to this
intervention they basically just kind of
shifted their calories around to
accommodate it what they found is that
ectopic lipid deposition and
postprandial glycogen storage in the
liver and skeletal muscle were not
altered they found that there this
eight-week intervention of very high
fructose intake was not associated with
any meaningful adverse metabolic
consequences so the big thing to keep in
mind here is that these people were at a
pretty stable energy intake they didn't
see a huge increase in total calories
body weight was slightly reduced but not
not to a major degree over the course of
the intervention but basically what this
study shows in a nutshell is
if you're a young metabolically healthy
person who is controlling your overall
energy intake and maintaining your body
weight at a relatively stable spot
fructose intakes even up to this really
high number of a hundred and fifty grams
a day they really don't seem to be as
catastrophic as you might believe when
it comes to these different metabolic
outcomes so good news for the people who
like fruit and just to put that in
perspective you know it's not exactly
50/50 but I think high fructose corn
syrup and a lot of beverages is like
what 55 45 so putting that those numbers
in perspective I mean we're talking
about like getting nearly 300 grams of
sugar per day from soft drinks to match
this level of fructose intake so this is
about as high as anyone worried about
their health would ever possibly
approach even if they had really high
fruit intake and the takeaway from this
study is as long as you've got all your
ducks in a row for your diet in terms of
making sure your energy balance is
appropriate turns out not that bad it's
good to hear okay now Greg I see in our
very carefully constructed outline the
next segment is is called only knee
sleeve hypothesis yeah we can we can
stick with hot off the press oh okay
because these are two pretty recent
studies so there was a study recently
published title is biomechanical
modeling of deep squatting colon effects
of the interface contact between
posterior thigh and shank by Wu at all
and so essentially what this study was
doing is as the title implies it was
biomechanical modeling so you take data
that you've collected of people
squatting and then you kind of take data
of how basically how thick hamstrings
and calves tend to be some tissue
properties and you look and see if
someone squats deep how much are those
tissues going to compress against each
other and then how is that going to
affect forces on the knee and so what
they found in
modeling work is that contact between
your calves and hamstrings when you
squat deep reduces patella femoral and
tibial femoral contact forces in the
kind of 40 to 60% range which is which
is pretty substantial and so this got me
thinking this got me thinking about knee
sleeves and it got me thinking about
knee sleeves because I get a lot of
questions about knee sleeves but there
aren't
there's vanishingly little research
about them I think there might be two or
three papers including one that was very
recently published which I'll talk about
in a second but yeah there's a bunch of
bunch of papers that look at squatting
in general in both healthy populations
and populations of people with
musculoskeletal disorders just I mean
it's it's probably one of the movements
that humans do that is the most heavily
studied after you know probably walking
running and jumping but yeah a lot of
stuff looking at squats in general and
there are a handful of papers looking at
knee wraps as well not a ton but kind of
three four maybe five papers on knee
wraps but very very little on knee
sleeves and so when people ask me
questions I can say like well okay if we
think through this logically here's what
I think would probably be happening but
you know there wasn't really research to
point to and one of the one of the
things that you can I guess kind of
surmise about knee sleeves just thinking
through things logically is they
shouldn't help you in the same way that
knee wraps help you
so knee wraps are they're super tight
and they're elastic and when you squat
down as the material stretches it stores
elastic energy and it can actually exert
a knee extension moment to like actively
help you stand up out of the bottom of a
squat knee sleeves might do that to some
degree but to a enormous Li lesser
extent when compared to near apps and so
when people talk about knee sleeves
they'll
often say like you know maybe it helps
my squad a little bit but really it just
helps my knees feel a lot more
comfortable when I squat that's that's
the common thing that people will say
and the hypothesis I've heard to explain
that before is oh well it just helps
lock in heat and so it makes the joint
warmer maybe it kind of helps your
synovial fluid be a little warmer and
flow a little better or whatever and
maybe that's what is making your knees
feel better when you wear knee sleeves
to squat and I never really found that
all that convincing just because blood
flow to your legs is going to increase
so much just from squatting anyways so
you know you know maybe if you train in
a really cold gym and you're only doing
really low reps and you're resting 10
minutes between sets
maybe maybe you're not gonna have enough
blood flow to bring the temperature up
in the joint but otherwise I feel like
you're not gonna get that much just
heating benefit from sleeves or like it
will probably raise the temperature of
the joint a little bit but probably the
it probably wouldn't be necessary
like just exercising would probably
bring the temperature up enough to have
some sort of functional benefit if that
is kind of where that benefit was coming
from but seeing this recent paper made
me think that maybe what's actually
going on is nice leaves also affecting
patella femoral and tibial femoral
contact forces and I'm primarily
interested in the patella femoral
contact forces here because when you
look at the forces on the knee joint in
the squat really if you have healthy
knees for the most part like things
should be fine
but there's some research suggesting
that the patella femoral contact forces
in the squat are are possibly high
enough that they could cause
degenerative changes to the retro
patellar cartilage which you know
probably not something everyone needs to
be worried about probably not
particularly scary but something that
you could potentially be a problem for
some
people and so one of the things you know
if you squat with nice leaves is they do
kind of like bunch up behind your knees
a little bit and so in effect they would
be adding to kind of what you get from
hamstring calf contact so if the the
contact between your hamstrings and
calves can reduce patella femoral
contact forces adding nice leaves into
the mix might actually magnify that to
further reduce contact forces within the
knee joint during deep squats and so
that is that is now kind of my working
hypothesis for why a lot of people just
you know self-report that their knees
feel a lot more comfortable when they
squat in sleeves to me at least that
seems like a more plausible mechanism
than you know just to the knee sleeves
heating the joint up and there's maybe
slight support for that really it really
this is just validating things that
people have been subjectively reporting
for a long time but there was another
recent study hot off the presses called
acute effects of knee wraps / sleeves on
kinetics kinematics and muscle forces
during the barbell back squat by
Sinclair and colleagues and in that
study basically they found that wearing
sleeves didn't really affect kinematics
of the squat to any meaningful degree
which is what you should expect because
they aren't actually actively aiding in
knee extension really to any meaningful
degree however perceived comfort and
perceived stability were greater when
people wore knee sleeves on average than
when they squatted without sleeves and
not so much the stability that's
probably just joint compression but the
perceived comfort you know that that
matches what people have been self
reporting for a long time and like I
said I think that potentially has
something to do with reducing patella
femoral contact forces magnifying what
would already naturally be happening
just from contact between the hamstrings
and calves very nice
I gotta be honest I'm probably like the
last person the lifting world I've never
actually tried nice leaves you know I
had never worn them until I don't know
maybe last year two years ago I was
never gonna buy them but then SBD and a7
both sent me some free pairs thanks guys
they're both awesome I like them a lot
the first time I wore them I hated them
I'm like I'm weird about touch and I
don't like things to be sticky basically
like that I think that bothers me a lot
more than most people and so like when
my knees would sweat when I was wearing
sleeves I really really just did not dig
that feeling and so the first time I
wore sleeves I don't think I wore them
again for like another two and a half
months but then I was like yeah I'll
give them at another shot people seem to
like them maybe I just need to get used
to them and like yeah it's not a night
and day difference if I forget to bring
my sleeves to the gym I'm not gonna
catastrophize it like I really don't
think they affect my performance at all
but yeah I mean they do kind of make my
knees feel nice and and I don't have
knee pain like I have to this point in
my life my knees have pretty much been
bulletproof which is nice except the
time when I was playing football and
called a helmet to the side of my knee
and tore my MCL but otherwise they've
been good in terms of like dealing with
lifting stress but yeah I'm like they
never hurt but they do still feel better
with sleeves if that makes sense
yeah now that I think about it I when I
was like training for a powerlifting
meet I did wear like I used to wrestle
back in the day and sometimes we'd wear
like a cotton sleeve over our knee just
to slide on the mat a little easier I
did wear those sometimes when they were
just feeling really rusty especially in
the winter so I don't want to perjure
myself on the podcast I have done that
and there's probably videos of me
squatting in them somewhere on the
Internet
but but yeah for me I felt like you know
it felt nice to keep them
there's no elasticity whatsoever for
those kinds of nice leaves but you know
they were warm and I will say they kind
of mentally gave me a bit of a crutch I
was like ooh look at these reinforced
knees that are now squatting even though
realistically it's like there's nothing
going on there yeah yeah one of these
days I might it might improve the
lateral forces your knee could withstand
by two Newtons
exactly yeah one of these days I'm gonna
try the real sleeves I think okay moving
on I've got a little research roundup
segment and our regular listeners will
know that the research roundup we talked
about a small collection of studies we
give kind of brief overviews rather than
doing a super deep dive into any
singular study and I've got a themed
research roundup here and the theme is
there's a lot of variability when it
comes to how easily someone can lose
weight you know some people have a
tremendous amount of difficulty with
their weight loss
some people find weight loss to be a
fairly straightforward and easy process
and I think I find myself on in the
position that when I try to lose weight
it usually goes quite easily and I would
like to pretend it's because I'm simply
better than everyone that struggles with
weight loss but I find that hard to
believe that always kills me when people
kind of struggle with the the empathy
involved there and they're like oh it's
easy for me so how could anyone struggle
with this well I've got found a
collection of studies that help us begin
to understand some of the factors that
go into variability when it comes to you
know whether or not you find a weight
loss to be extremely easy extremely
difficult or more likely somewhere in
between so on a previous episode we
talked very briefly about a paper by
Ortega Santos and colleagues it was
called the key to successful weight loss
on a high-fiber diet may relate now I'm
paraphrasing the title but it may relate
to the gut microbiome privat ella
abundance I like started reading the
sentence verbatim and then I was like
I'm just gonna prep paraphrases okay the
actual title the key to successful
weight loss on a high-fiber diet may be
in gut microbiome Prevotella abundance
and the idea was
based on your gut microbiome going into
the study that seemed to dictate how
successful this high-fiber diet
intervention was in terms of weight loss
and that kind of piqued my interest in
keeping an eye on the literature for
studies that also seemed to indicate
like what are some interesting things
that might relate to variability with
weight loss outcomes so a recent study
by Holstein at all I'm going to read the
title with the actual words this time
metabolic response to fasting predicts
weight gain during low protein over
feeding in lean men further evidence for
spendthrift
and thrifty metabolic phenotypes so the
idea here was to look at the response to
a 24-hour fast and see if that was
predictive of how readily people gained
fat when they were overfed for a six
week period so they had seven lean men
that participated in the study that's a
small number especially for a study with
only one group but you're gonna see why
that is shortly so what they did was
they measured their metabolic response
to a 24-hour fast and then they put them
on the six-week overfeeding diet it was
a hundred and fifty percent of their
energy needs but it was a very low
protein diet it was only 2% protein very
very low so that that is a caveat to
keep in mind this is not necessarily a
typical diet but I don't think it
necessarily confounds the conclusions
that I would take from the study one
thing to keep in mind about this study
is that it was super well controlled so
I mentioned they had seven people that
actually like you know enrolled and
completed this thing they were admitted
to an inpatient unit for 76 days so 76
days in an inpatient ward here and just
keep that in mind when you look at
studies like this like if I'm away from
my home for 10 days I go nuts because my
home is designed the way I want it to be
designed everything set up the way I
like it it's my place where I'm
comfortable and productive imagine
enrolling in a study like this and just
being like a 76 days I'm gonna go stay
at this metabolic Ward yeah that's wild
that sucks yeah so a huge thank you to
the people that actually volunteer for
these
the studies it's really really important
did they say how much the subjects were
paid I I don't think so
I remember around the time I was in high
school
NASA was recruiting for a study where it
was it was basically going to be I
believe a 60-day bedrest study and they
were gonna pay participants I believe 20
grand for it
whoa yeah and so that was my graduation
plan if I didn't get into college but
the the reason the reason that's
relevant is man I think it took them
three years to recruit for that study
even dangling 20 grand in front of
prospective participants which like I
mean there are a lot of people who could
really use 20 grand who are unemployed
and keep in mind like I graduated in
2010 I first saw the ads in 2009 that's
when a lot of people are still out of
work after the financial crisis big-time
and yeah and like I said I'm pretty sure
the study was 60 days I'm going off of
memory I haven't revisited this since
probably 2011 but I want to say it was
20 grand for 60 days and they had a hell
of a time recruiting for it so man they
must have had quite the carrot to get
people to stay in that metabolic Ward
for 76 days in this study yeah and I
don't recall the number off the top of
my head but I do remember seeing that
their enrollment period spanned a number
of years yeah that they did report that
and that makes a lot of sense yeah which
is crazy cause like you know the typical
study and exercise science it's like
hopefully we can get our recruiting done
in two months you know what I mean yeah
now to measure metabolic rate they used
one of these really cool metabolic
chambers it was like a whole room where
they can measure your energy expenditure
they can also measure things like
spontaneous physical physical activity
which they they measure using radar
sensors and they can even get really
sophisticated indices of your sleeping
metabolic rate and distinguish that from
your waking metabolic rate
so um this is the type of study where it
was just absolutely incredibly well
controlled they spared no expense so the
data are really quite reliable obviously
the trade-off is the small sample size
they even went so far the the
participants were videotaped daily while
they ate their meals and then they
reviewed the videotapes to make sure
that they consumed exactly what they
were supposed to and then they took
direct measurements of calories from
their nutrient intake but they also
collected feces and urine and measured
the energy content of their feces and
urine and a you know key spots
throughout the study to try to at least
quantify some of the energy loss due to
incomplete absorption of calories so
very very thorough very tightly
controlled the results of the study
during the 24 hour fast
total daily energy expenditure on
average decreased by about a hundred and
sixty calories per day during the over
feeding period they gained on average
three point eight kilograms but the
really interesting findings here were in
the correlations okay so what they found
was some people relative to the average
had smaller reductions in energy
expenditure during fasting so basically
when they were exposed to fasting they
their energy expenditure didn't drop as
much as the others and those are the
same people that had less weight gain
during the over feeding period so they
were less able to kind of down regulate
energy expenditure during the famine or
the fasting period but they were also
less able to store a bunch of energy
during the feasting period or the over
feeding so these people are pretty well
equipped to successfully lose weight
when they go on a weight-loss diet they
don't see you know a large degree of
metabolic adaptation to slow them down
and when they try to overfeed they're
generally unsuccessful if they're trying
to you know intentionally put on weight
so if you're someone who we talked about
this last episode considers yourself a
hard gainer this might be the phenotype
that that describes your general
metabolic activity so you might do
really well when you try to lose weight
and you find it to be fairly easy not a
lot of friction there but when you try
to overfeed to intentionally gain weight
your body might really ramp up its
metabolic rate and make it difficult for
you to lose or to gain weight when
you're trying to now the inverse of that
some people had a pretty large reduction
in energy expenditure during the fasting
period so basically these are the people
who would say I caught the metabolic
adaptation and I got it bad you know
they go on this weight loss diet dig
reduction in energy expenditure and they
struggle with weight loss these were the
very same people that during the
overfeeding period they more easily
gained weight so these are people who
are extremely well-equipped to deal with
feast and famine cycles so like you know
now many of us are fortunate enough that
we don't have to really seriously worry
about food security you know generally
speaking you know where your next meal
is coming from and and that's a very
fortunate place to be and obviously not
everybody's in that position but you
know especially in in fairly wealthy
countries that is the case but you know
if we think back to a time where we're
having good stable food security was
just simply not realistic you know
before supermarkets and grocery stores
and stuff these people would have been
with this particular phenotype would
have been set up really well you know
when food is not available they just
down regulate their energy expenditure
when there's plenty of food around they
easily store fat so they can hold on to
some of that energy for later so these
are people who are probably likely to
struggle with weight loss and say I
don't know I did reduce my calories but
it's not working as well as I thought it
would the only upside to that is if
these people were trying to bulk up they
probably have a pretty pretty easy time
doing it now we can't necessarily infer
that they would necessarily have a
really favorable response in terms of
how much of that weight gain was muscle
and how much was fat but you know these
people certainly wouldn't consider
themselves hardgainers in the sense that
they try over feeding and they just
can't get the scale of the bunch upward
so this is interesting because it
because of these correlations it really
presents you with these two distinct
phenotypes
some people who can lose weight fairly
easily but struggle to put on weight if
they try and then the the inverse of
that would be people who really struggle
with weight loss but if they try to
increase body weight by overfeeding
they're usually pretty successful at
that and you know Greg you grew up in
the gym culture I did - you would always
have that one buddy who was jealous of
everyone that was gaining weight right
he's our I I just can't do it I keep
trying but you also had that buddy who
would bulk like crazy and get huge and
strong but then he'd be like yeah I
tried losing weight again it didn't
didn't really pan out I was that buddy
so yeah I mean and I've always been in
the situation where I find cutting a lot
easier than bulking generally speaking
so so this is one of those things where
you see the data and you're like oh yeah
me and my buddies figured that out when
we were 17 right but but it is nice to
see this really well controlled research
showing that these these differential
responses - under under feeding and over
feeding are indeed correlated and it
gives you some hope if you're operating
under the assumption that every human
being in the world wants to be both
enormous and shredded at the same time
and I refuse to accept that I might be
wrong with that assumption everyone
wants to be enormous and shredded that's
my worldview I mean that's either what
people want or they're lying to
themselves exactly again sarcasm is part
of the show guys but the good news is
there's a high likelihood that you
either find yourself pretty in the
middle where you know you can kind of
lose weight or gain weight with some
degree of ease or at least minimal
friction but if you do find yourself
really hard or really far on one side of
the spectrum or the other at least half
of the battle should be kind of easy
right you should at least be able to
bulk and then struggle to cut yeah
you've got something going for you
theoretically you should have something
going for you so there's some good news
and some bad news which is nice yeah
it's nice now one thing to keep in mind
there's a very small sample so for these
correlations there were only six people
with complete data to use but we what we
are talking about correlations in the
0.8 to 0.9 range so
the magnitude of the correlation in
terms of how well those data points fit
on a line was pretty solid but there
were very few data points now you if you
want to you can be the person that
complains about nutrition studies not
having good control so I they didn't
really manipulate all the variables that
need to be manipulated they didn't
control every extraneous factor you can
be that person you could also be the
person who complains about sample size
all the time say oh twelve people know
what am I supposed to do with that but
you can't be both you know you have to
either embrace like okay this was a very
small study but Wow
kudos to them for really controlling
everything this is valuable but like it
always kills me when people see the big
studies with minimal control and they're
like ah useless they didn't control it
and then they see a small study like
this and they say six people why would I
care about that I mean there is a third
type of person with a very different
criticism that very much applies to this
paper what would that be they didn't
even try to keto adapt them and if they
did 76 days isn't anywhere near long
enough yeah but that is that is the
third group and completely completely
submerge the podcast we've done two
enormous segments on keto and we've
always presented very fair viewpoints on
it and you choose to come in with a
cheap shot like that and just invert the
entire operation I mean I'm assuming
those people don't listen to our show
yeah probably not but this is just one
more thing to add to the Greg Nickels
apology list Greg is gonna get a we're
gonna have the lawyers draft up another
statement for him to read on the next
show maybe I will repeat my previous
statement I'm not at all sorry about
what I said but I regret and this is the
key word if it hurt anyone's feelings
correct no-fault admitted so the thing I
would implore readers to do is when you
see a study don't just immediately say
unless there's 300 subs
that all lived in a metabolic Ward for
six months I'm not interested you gotta
you gotta give some you got to budge a
little bit on in one direction or the
other so I think this is a great example
of a study where we said you know what
sample size is small big deal we're
gonna control everything tightly and get
some really solid observations and I
think it's a really valuable study for
that so that was just one of the studies
I wanted to discuss like I said the
other ones I'm gonna speak about in a
little bit less detail and the reason
for that is because I'm about to very
cautiously tiptoe outside of what I
would consider my area of expertise and
the further I get away from that area
the less I generally speak so I'm going
to wade into waters in which I do not
belong and very cautiously share some
results so recent study by Buckland at
all the study is called women with a low
satiety phenotype show impaired appetite
control and greater resistance to weight
loss and so for this study obviously the
sample was all women and they looked at
something called a satiety quotient and
there there are a few different ways to
operationally define satiety quotient
but the general idea is they are
quantifying the degree to which
individuals feel sated or satisfied in
response to a meal so they'll they'll
see before a meal how hungry are you or
what is your motivation to eat right now
in a numerical scale they'll give a
standardized meal they'll measure it
afterward and they're basically saying
who really has a big impact in their
motivation to eat in response to this
meal and some people with a high satiety
phenotype they eat a meal they're
totally satisfied low motivation to eat
afterwards some people that they're a
low satiety phenotype even after that
meal they're like yeah I'll eat more you
know it just doesn't really move the
needle the way you'd want it to okay so
the the thing to keep in mind here is
they they divided them into low and high
satiety phenotypes in terms of grouping
and what they did was like I said this
is a continuous type of variable and
they basically just kind of split the
group
so we've talked in the past about how
that is in approach people use that in
many cases can be limited you know when
you have a continuous variable and you
chop it into a couple groups but
nonetheless you know there are some
instances where it does make the
interpretation a lot easier what they
found with this study to kind of put it
all in a nutshell the results indicated
that people with the low satiety
phenotype actually experience less
weight loss during an ad libitum weight
loss program so there are these they
could have been put on one of two weight
loss programs spanning about 14 weeks
and what they found was whether or not
you were in the low or high satiety
phenotype designation actually was
relatively predictive of how successful
you would be on that future weight loss
attempt and so this is a pretty
intuitive finding but it is one of those
things where we can bring people in the
lab and measure some of these things
that can be predictive of you know how
well is this weight loss attempt likely
to go and so this isn't by any means a
jaw-dropping revelation in terms of the
outcome but it is interesting to see in
laboratory environments that we that we
can see this type of variability with
responses to similar weight loss
programs that that actually makes a lot
of sense I'm blanking on the name of it
I just remembered so there is a gene
that people colloquially refer to as the
fat gene FTO and it's like so no single
gene is going to have that large of an
impact on like obesity phenotype but in
terms of single genes that seem to be
the most strongly correlated with rates
of obesity FTO seems to be the leading
candidate at the moment and one thing to
note about it is when they've done
well-controlled studies they've done
this a couple times where they do like
control everything a person does like
their standardized activity their
standardized diets they look at weight
loss success based on FTO genotype it
doesn't have really any meaningful
impact on success of the
weight loss but in like ad libitum just
free living environments people with
that particular genotype do tend to wind
up several kilos heavier and it does
seem to have a lot to do with hunger and
satiety so essentially it doesn't really
affect metabolism like you know if if
you were a robot and could you know
stick to a plan a hundred percent that
that particular genotype wouldn't really
have any meaningful impact but it does
seem to impact over time people's
choices and behaviors because of the
degree to which it impacts hunger and
satiety so that that very much ties in
with this study
definitely yeah and and the next study
I'm gonna talk about kind of adds
another wrinkle to this so the next
study is by Yocum and spice Yocum and
spice with a tea I said spice cuz
everything nice I'm thinking food this
is a long title bear with me it's called
weight gain is associated with changes
in neural response to palatal palatable
food tastes varying in sugar and fat and
palatable food images a
repeated-measures fMRI study feel like
they needed to workshop that one a
little bit it's too long I got
sidetracked in the middle of it but
anyway that's what the title is if you
want look it up so the idea here is they
did a baseline fMRI and then they
repeated that two or three years later
and fMRI is basically when they bring
people in the lab they do that the MRI
thing of the brain where it lights up
with different colors and they say oh
well when we when we gave them chocolate
the I like chocolate region of the brain
really lit up that makes sense so they
just give a stimulus they look at which
part of the brain gets really bright and
colorful and they're like okay we see
what's going on in that brain that's
pretty much the general principle okay
so what they do with the study is they
they found that at baseline some people
had a hyper you know a really
exaggerated response when it when it
comes to the FM fMRI indicators of taste
processing activity in response to
palatable food
and what they found was that the people
who had this really exaggerated response
to palatable food were more likely to
gain weight over that two to three year
observation period so so the idea was
you know it was essentially looks looked
to be a predisposing factor where the
people who had these really big
increases in this taste processing
activity you know a really exaggerated
response to good tasting very palatable
food that seemed to be predictive of
weight gain over that two to three year
period now they did repeat the fMRI
stuff after that period and they found
that after weight gain that responsivity
decreased so it it wasn't quite as
exaggerated after that weight gain
occurred so like I said I try not to
talk as much when I start venturing
outside of my area of expertise you
might infer based on my description of
how fMRI works this isn't really my
thing but you know you see that this
hyper responsiveness kind of gets toned
down after the weight loss it was
predictive of the weight loss but kind
of levels off after a while I can't help
but wonder if that's a good or a bad
thing just speculating so I could see
you saying okay well now that you've
gained the weight you know maybe these
palatable foods are no longer novel and
so your brain response to that isn't
quite as exaggerated like during that
weight gain process you probably had
exposure to plenty of palatable foods
one would imagine and now you've kind of
chilled out and kind of plateaued and
been like it's not as special as it used
to be but I could also I also wonder if
it might possibly be a driver to kind of
seek that rewarding experience even more
where you're like man having those
palatable foods doesn't really give me
the that response I used to get maybe
I'll have more of them or go for even
more palatable food combinations I
really don't know what to make of that
this is just me recklessly speculating
yeah I mean it could be a lot like the
number one gateway truck
marijuana's I mean first you do one one
toke and it makes you feel good and then
next thing you know you have to inject
three whole lines of marijuana to get
the same high and you move on to the
harder stuff it could be very similar to
that I'm gonna be so upset if there's
someone out there who still thinks that
you're like a staunch you know anti
marijuana crusader I'm gonna be so upset
moving on I think I have one they're not
gonna make it this far in the no yeah
they're done they've already they've
already they unsubscribe two episodes
ago
yeah and crushed us on the internet and
now the internet algorithm overlords are
gonna just exile us to the most isolated
corner of the internet I think that's
how reviews work right I think so yeah
okay last review or last study to talk
about in this research roundup is by
Klatt skin' at all it says negative
effect is associated with increased
stress eating for women with high
perceived life stress so just to you
know negative effect it's a personality
variable that involves the experience of
negative emotions and poor self-concept
and negative affectivity could describe
a variety of negative emotions including
anger contempt disgust guilt fear and
nervousness so what they found in this
study again this is one of those
outcomes that's relatively unsurprising
it kind of passes that face of validity
test of like yeah that that's pretty
intuitive but what they found was in
women with perceived life stress
negative effect was predictive of stress
eating and they're thinking that might
be because there are greater drops in
negative effect after stress eating for
women who have high perceived life
stress so they stress eat mnek basically
is like a coping mechanism and they say
yeah that I feel a little bit better now
the problem there is that higher
perceived life stress predicted greater
emotional relief upon stress eating so
it might reinforce that idea like a
learned association in these people with
high perceived life stress okay
when I get stressed or have a negative
effect I'm gonna go do some stress
eating that's gonna make me feel better
and they kind of learned that feedback
loop and are more likely to potentially
repeat it and so the authors indicated
that the results might help to explain
why there is greater stress eating and
greater obesity in women who tend to
have higher perceived life stress the
idea that it reinforces this behavior of
you know I have perceived live stress
when I have negative effect or negative
emotions I lean on stress eating it
gives me kind of a short-term reward
sensation that's kind of a
self-perpetuating loop that predisposes
one to obesity
yeah I've seen kind of that similar idea
posited as a potential link between
poverty and obesity which I mean that's
plausible as hell very much so so like I
said once I start getting into more
behavioral stuff I try to speak less
just to make sure I'm not being an idiot
but when we look at the collective
literature when it comes to things that
affect weight loss variability and this
is an incomplete list for sure but some
of the things that might predispose one
to either have very low friction during
a weight loss attempt or you know very
high friction and a lot of difficulty it
could relate to your metabolic phenotype
do you you know really abruptly adapt to
local organ take as a means of
preserving fat mass some people do some
people not quite as much it could relate
you know the study that I mentioned from
a previous episode episode it could
relate to your gut microbiome there
seems to be some influence of that with
certain types of diet interventions it
could relate to your subjective satiety
response to eating those satiety
phenotypes that we talked about it could
relate to neurobiological factors
related to reward sensations so that
study where people had this really big
kind of pleasurable brain activity in
response to palatable foods that seemed
to be predictive of waking it could be
related to perceived live stress and the
propensity that one might
to resort to stress eating as a means of
dealing with negative affect in within
the context of life stressors could
relate to sleep which we've talked about
about you know several times before on
the podcast general principle here it's
pretty complicated so whether you're
trying to lose weight or whether you
work with people who might be trying to
lose weight it's really important to
keep that in mind and I think a lot of
people I think one of the unfortunate
things about this like evidence-based
fitness thing that that seems to be
really popular right now generally on
the whole it's a good thing but I think
a lot of people have adopted a very
oversimplified view of weight loss which
is you give everyone a pretty
predictable number of calories and
proportion of different macronutrients
and it will work and if it doesn't work
they're lying about their adherence I
think if we're going to take an
evidence-based approach to weight loss
or any any change in body composition we
have to review all the evidence
including all these other factors that
might predispose one to either have
better or worse adherence have a better
or worse time while adhering and then
things that could actually affect the
physiology of exactly how low or how
high two calories need to be yeah I
think I think a lot of people do get
kind of reductive when it comes to this
stuff have you seen the Bob Newhart
MADtv sketch stop it I think I have I
think I have so it's a classic if you're
listening to this and you haven't seen
it just google Bob Newhart stop it
or search that on YouTube it'll come up
this was a sketch from way back in the
day where it's essentially a young woman
coming to a therapist with you know a
lot of problems a lot of things she's
dealing with and his advice for
everything is well just stop it
and I feel like that's about as useful
as just giving people advice to eat less
move more
right because the thing is like yeah
like no [ __ ] that's what someone needs
to do but like that doesn't address why
they may be struggling with it it
doesn't address you know potential
strategies that they could try to
implement to you know make eating less
and moving more a simpler habit to adopt
and stick with so it's like it's true
but thoroughly unhelpful right yeah and
that's the thing that I try to reinforce
like I think a lot of people who would
be helping someone with weight loss
probably I'm just playing the numbers
here playing the averages in aggregate
they're probably people with a pretty
nice physique
generally speaking you know if you're
like a fitness professional who people
come to for weight loss you're probably
kind of lean ish and the really
important thing to keep it or you've
gotten very lean at some point one would
think generally it's really important if
you're someone who has not struggled
with weight loss but you're trying to
help clients who do it's really
important that you step outside of your
own experiences and be evidence-based
the stuff is still evidence too it's
it's not just like a macro spreadsheet
but it is evidence it's really important
to step outside of your own personal
experience and think why would this be
would this client be having a much
harder time than I would some of these
factors relate to adherence some of them
relate to to true physiological
differences some relate to how they're
going to experience this weight loss
attempt how unpleasant or challenging
it's going to be perceived on there and
and and what kind of roadblocks are
going to be in their way and as a
practitioner I'm not trying to sometimes
people talk about these different
aspects that affect adherence and they
think you're trying to make excuses for
people with poor adherence that's really
not what the conversation should be
about if you're a practitioner the whole
point is what are our challenges and
what are the strategies these are some
of the challenges and these are things
that are gonna vary widely so when
you've got those clients that are really
struggling keep this evidence in mind
and start to think about well these are
some of the potential
blocks we might be dealing with what are
some strategies to help navigate these
but please don't be the person who's
been lean your entire life is always
shredded and then convinces themselves
people who aren't shredded just don't
want it bad enough you know there there
are real differences between people that
can describe and explain this
variability in weight loss responses I
mean yeah that may also not be untrue
like they just don't want it bad enough
because the thing is so I'm speaking as
someone who has always always struggled
with my weight and like one time in my
life when I was dealing with a
tremendous amount of just like
self-loathing I was like I want to be
lean
I wanted it really bad and I lost like
60 pounds in four months and like the
thing is I think virtually everyone if
you said like hey I took your family
hostage and I'm gonna kill him in three
months unless you unless you lose thirty
pounds I think virtually everyone could
get it done but then the question is
like is it reasonable to expect someone
to want it that bad and are you going to
judge them if they don't because like
you know if you're let's say you're a
professional bodybuilder and you're one
of like the five professional
bodybuilders in the world who actually
makes their income off of competition
winnings then like yeah there's a very
clear reason why someone would want it
really bad but you know someone who has
a busy life and like fitness is just
kind of a hobby for them and they want
to lose some weight but like you know
it's not a life-or-death situation
there's not a tremendous amount of money
on the line if they are able to get lean
or not then the general strategy of well
you just gotta want it bad enough it's
like they're they're clearly struggling
because like you know the the amount of
the amount to which it rationally
matters to them doesn't kind of comport
with how much it would suck to achieve
what they want - given the strategies
they have so like
your job as a coach is to make it to
where like the amount of willpower that
they rationally have and the amount that
they rationally want it can kind of
match up better with the amount of
effort they have to put into it via the
strategies that you give them it's a
very important clarification if weight
loss is the goal obviously you you can
willpower your way as far as you want to
go if you just said all right it's
chicken and spinach from here on out
we're gonna go on seven eight hundred
calories a day carry that in perpetuity
you're gonna get very lean and probably
not be healthy
you're probably gonna run into a lot of
issues but but absolutely yeah I mean
you could if you wanted it bad enough
obviously you could make your life
absolutely miserable and just go for it
you know I mean no one is immune to
starvation so you could take as extreme
approach as you wanted and it's the
calories in and the calories out still
work but but that's a very important
clarification what I'm indicating is you
know you've got one client who runs into
a lot of roadblocks it's important to
consider what might be the predisposing
factors that are causing these
roadblocks to come up it's just gonna
make you a better practitioner for like
you said getting them we're you know
taking the amount of willpower and
dedication they have toward that goal
and maximizing how we apply strategies
to get as much out of that as we can and
yeah if you've got a client who this is
absolutely the only priority in their
life and they're willing to do anything
they're gonna get lean it will work but
but the real trick is when you've got
that client who is struggling with a
variety of different barriers and you're
like I just can't figure out what is
making this so hard for them that's
where those evidence comes into play you
know how do they how do they respond to
palatable foods what can we do about
that do we have to maybe consider the
fact that maybe those palatable foods
are not going to be part of your
low-calorie diet plan some people can
get those treats in there and it's fine
other people it just
causes them to overeat excessively you
know that the cliche one is peanut
butter some people when they're dieting
there's just no peanut butter in the
house and that's just the way it goes
you know but some people can just have a
little bit and still maintain a
low-calorie diet and it's fine so it's a
very good clarification I don't want to
discount how important it is to have the
focus and the willpower to focus in on
the goal and make it happen but as a
practitioner all this evidence here
about these different predisposing
factors it's just more tools in the
toolbox that are gonna help you get more
clients to reach the goals they're
they're interested in yeah and it it's
it's kind of the same type of type of
thing like just the observation oh you
don't want it bad enough while true may
also not be useful correct because like
just telling someone that isn't gonna
make them want it more right definitely
ok that just about does it for today's
episode but as always we need something
to play us out so Greg I had the
tremendous pleasure of being a guest at
your Thanksgiving I know what you're
thinking listener Thanksgiving was two
weeks ago but Greg's fixated on it he
can't get over it clearly it's his
favorite holiday of the year
so Greg you made the turkey it was
absolutely phenomenal can you share some
roasted turkey tips for our listeners
yeah so the the reason I'm doing this is
I posted a little bit about making a
good turkey on Facebook and it was
really really popular so generally
that's where that's where recipes stuff
on the podcast comes from like if I
share something on Facebook and
Instagram and it has a big response it's
like okay let's try to get this out to
more people so you know if you're
listening to this there's a decent
chance you're not going to make another
turkey for you know another 50 weeks or
so but maybe just bookmark this and come
back to it around this time next year
and some people do Christmas turkeys
they do so this will be very useful if
you do a Christmas turkey
yeah or you know if your Thanksgiving
turkey didn't go well and you won't read
em
for Christmas you could make that a new
tradition for you and your family so
anyway here are just some tips to get a
good turkey because turkey can be
absolutely delicious but most turkeys
that are consumed out there for
Thanksgiving are just absolutely horrid
if you properly cook a turkey it can be
juicy and flavorful and so good and if
you overcook it or cook it poorly which
I think most people do it's gonna be dry
and you're gonna have to absolutely
smother it in gravy for you to even be
able to choke it down and it's just an
unpleasant experience so if you want to
get the most out of your turkey here's
what you gotta do so first things first
if you started cooking turkeys like 10
years ago or 20 years ago and you
learned from the Food and Drug
Administration or the USDA that the safe
cooking temperature for poultry was 180
degrees that's wrong that's what they
said back in the day they have since
revised it to a hundred and sixty-five
degrees if you cook it low and slow so
so pasteurizing food is both a matter of
time and temperature so essentially like
the the temperature that they say this
is safe is the temperature at which if
the if the meat Peaks above that
temperature for an instant all of the
bacteria are dead if you hold it at a
slightly lower temperature for a
slightly longer period of time that will
also accomplish pasteurization so
realistically if you go low and slow
cooking your bird you could probably eat
it at like 155 160 but 165 that is the
number that is absolutely going to be
safe that's what the FDA has revised it
to and that will still give you a juicy
delicious bird so in addition to the
cooking temperature some things to keep
in mind one I would strongly strongly
recommend you brine your turkey so what
that's going to do is it's going to help
you get some salt into the meat just so
it's a little bit more flavorful
and it is also going to help break down
the proteins so as the proteins break
down as you cook those proteins are
going to hold on to a little more water
and it's just going to make the meat
softer and more tender in general so as
far as brining goes you can either go
with a wet brine or a dry brine I
personally tend to dry brine steaks and
wet brine turkeys so a wet brine is
essentially you make a saltwater
solution and you submerge the the piece
of meat in that and just let it hang out
at least overnight but two days is
probably better dry brine is essentially
you would like put the bird on a
roasting rack and just cover it pretty
heavily in salt and just let it rest
again at least overnight that's
initially going to draw some water out
of the meat and then draw the then
salted water back into the meat I've
heard from people that dry brine in
Turkey works well I only cook one turkey
a year and I've always had great success
with wet brining and so I'm not gonna
like risk my yearly Turkey dry brining
because I know what brining works well
if you go the wet brining route I would
recommend a two to three percent
solution so essentially for every liter
of liter of water you use you'd want to
have twenty to thirty grams of salt
dissolved in that water that's going to
give you enough salt in the meat to
accomplish what you want it to do
without just making it overly
unpleasantly salty so yeah start by
brining the meat either wet or dry I
personally recommend wet because that's
what I've had success with next thing
you're gonna want to do and this one's
gonna sound weird but trust me it's
great
you want to spatchcock your bird
spatchcocking is a just kind of neat
term for removing the spine you're going
to have a lot more success with that
with a very sharp ideally well-made pair
of kitchen shears then you will a knife
if you have a really really sharp knife
you could probably spatchcock with a
knife I wouldn't recommend it I'd
recommend using kitchen shears
it's trivially easy to spatchcock a
chicken with a turkey since the bones
are thicker it does take a little more
elbow grease but it's worth it so once
you remove the spine you can kind of cut
down the middle of the breast from the
inside to get the turkey to lay flat and
what that's going to do is one is going
to help the bird cook faster because it
doesn't have the cavity inside that like
it's kind of a heat sink so it helps it
cook faster it also helps it cook a lot
more evenly so if you're roasting in an
oven you know you don't have the top of
the bird that's more exposed to the
heating element and the bottom that is
like kind of insulated to some degree
and it also just helps the meat cook
evenly through so one of the things that
can happen when you're cooking a turkey
is you could wind up with a bird that's
simultaneously overcooked and
undercooked like the most of the meat is
kind of overcooked and then when you get
like closer to the middle of the bird
like closer to the cavity it's still
partially raw spatchcocking helps reduce
the risk of that so the whole bird lays
flat it's a pretty uniform thickness
it's going to cook at a more even
desirable rate and like I said cook a
little bit faster as well so those are
the two biggest things I would recommend
if you brine your bird you Spach three
biggest things if you brine it you
spatchcock it and you make sure that at
the middle of the breast in the middle
of the thigh you're looking at
realistically pull the bird at 160 and
then carry over cooking we'll get it up
to 165 or if you just want to be
conservative and pull it at 165 that'll
get you a pretty good turkey so those
those are the three things that are
going to make the biggest difference now
a couple other things you could do that
will just kick it up another notch is
one after you pull the turkey out of the
brine and spatchcock it what I'd
recommend you do is Pat the skin dry and
then spray it down with cooking spray
you can also just like rub it down with
olive oil if you want but cooking spray
is a little bit easier and ultimately
adds a less fat to the bird if that's
something that matters to you and then
sprinkle a little salt on it the salt
will draw a
little bit of extra water and then
putting the fat on the skin will help it
crisp up nicely crisp turkey skin is
better than soggy turkey skin something
else that will help with crispy skin is
after the bird gets done roasting once
it hits the temperature you won't just
very very quickly crank the temperature
in the oven up as high as it'll go
ideally put it on broil and just put the
turkey in there for maybe 3 minutes or
so that's gonna crisp the skin up really
really nicely at the end of the cooking
process again without adding a bunch of
like internal heat to the muscles so
that's something I would recommend and
then finally and this is this is just
personal preference but I'd strongly
recommend it if you have a smoker if you
smoke
if you smoke a turkey it's gonna be so
good I mean smoking most meats makes
them better turkey itself is on the
blander end of birds so I don't think
turkey meat is just inherently quite as
bland as chicken but it is more bland
than most other birds getting some salt
in the meat from brining will help with
that but getting a nice layer of smoke
on the outside is its choice so I would
strongly recommend smoking your bird if
you do have access to a smoker as far as
cooking temp goes I have had the most
success generally cooking with a pretty
low temperature and then again at the
end just cranking it up to crisp up the
skin so somewhere between 275 and 325
degrees Fahrenheit that is what I have
had the most success with but just in
general like the the 3 biggest things
that I would I'd say the two biggest
things cooking temp get it up to 165 not
180 and again that's Fahrenheit not
Celsius and make sure you brine it
either wet or dry those are the two tips
that will give you the biggest return on
investment the next biggest tip that'll
give you the next highest return on
investment is to make sure you
spatchcock the bird it's not going to be
quite as important as brining or
appropriate cooking temperature but it
does make the
process a lot easier and make sure
things cook evenly so you don't wind up
with say overcook breast and undercooked
thighs so spatchcocking is really clutch
and then just the temp the
recommendations of smoking and using the
cooking spray on the skin and what not
that that I think are is kind of details
that will help put a little more polish
on the bird but really brine spatchcock
165 degrees that's that's where the
money is and I can confirm it was very
very good so in about 50 weeks be sure
to check back in to this episode or if
you want to give it a shot for a holiday
turkey this year go for it
and there's probably some transferable
skills here when it comes to cooking any
kind of poultry I would imagine oh yeah
spatchcocked roasted chicken tremendous
yeah if you if you like chicken and you
don't mind spending a little bit more
time prepping it I think we've talked
about this on the show before actually
brine the chicken
spatchcock it you know cook it nice and
slow it's absolutely delicious and even
if you're trying to go macro friendly
and you pick the skin off the underlying
meat is still going to be very delicious
and flavorful yeah and so that's an
alternative if you don't want to do it I
usually go with like a crock pot turkey
for Thanksgiving but this is a different
a different direction if you want to
make sure your Thanksgiving turkeys a
little bit more like a crock pot
boneless skinless turkey breast right
yeah several of them and I've put in
some chicken broth and I usually about
eight hours on the low setting would do
it oh just one tiny little thing to add
another further benefit of spatchcocking
your turkey is you can make sure you
have fresh turkey gravy so one of the
drawbacks of Thanksgiving in general is
if you want to have fresh gravy to go
with everything it's tough unless you
made turkey stock from your turkey last
year that you saved in the freezer
because like you know you make stock
from from the carcass of an animal that
has been picked and you don't get that
from the turkey you've roast for
Thanksgiving until
you have cooked it already and you're
probably not going to start the turkey
making process or the the gravy making
process until you've already completely
cooked and picked your turkey so a
benefit of spatchcocking is then you
have the neck that came with the turkey
and then also the spine which has a lot
of tendons and ligaments attached to it
a lot of collagen so while your cookie
is turqu or while your turkey is cooking
you can cut that spine up put it in a
stock pot and make fresh turkey stock
while your turkey is roasting so you can
have fresh turkey stock to make gravy
with there on the day which is pretty
cool very cool indeed that just about
does it for this week's episode but we
still have a fantastic interview we had
James Krieger on and we talked to James
a little bit about the insulin
hypothesis non-exercise activity
thermogenesis various types of body
composition measurement and then we just
kind of had a general conversation about
research and statistics in exercise
science so James is a good friend of
both of ours it's a really terrific
interview make sure you hang on and
listen to that on the other end of the
music
[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your host eric Trexler
today Greg and I are joined by the great
James Krieger James how are you doing
today good thanks for having me guys
thanks for coming on now I would imagine
that a huge portion of our audience
knows who you are
but there might be some who are not
familiar with you or your work so the
first question is who is James Krieger
and why well I'll answer the why first I
guess I guess you know if you haven't
had the birds and bees discussion that's
that that's how I came about but no I've
been in the fitness industry for she's
over 20 years now I I was around in the
early days of the internet back you know
maybe some of your older listeners who
have been around a while probably
remember some of the old message boards
like Amaya CDOT Fitness delt weights and
stuff I mean this is back in the early
to mid 90s
I used to lurk around those boards and
stuff and so I've been in the industry
ever you know since those times but but
yeah I've I kind of wear a lot of hats
I've published a number of studies or
been a co-author on a number of studies
in the industry you know with mainly
Bradshaw and fell but some other people
too you know mainly resistance training
studies meta analyses you know things
like that got my own I used to be a
research director for a weight
management program for for Microsoft
employees we had really good success
rates average weight loss of something
like 40 pounds in three months and that
program is still going you know even
though I'm not a part of it anymore it's
still growing really strong spaced here
in the Seattle area cuz that's where
Microsoft is but and have my own website
weight ology and have things like a
research review at some online coaching
go around I give talks and stuff I'm
really not a whole lot different from we
guys are doing you know you because you
guys got mass and and you got
you're you know stronger by science and
everything so uh no that's a good point
it it would seem a bit counterintuitive
that we would bring a direct competitor
on the show and less attention largely
to make them look bad and kind of
harpoon their business what do you think
well you still have subtle ways to do
that or perhaps I have subtle ways that
I could do it to you guys you know so
you know yeah but you don't edit the
audio so oh that's true all right so so
James I think that's a nice
comprehensive introduction I've seen you
speak in public and you're a really
fantastic speaker there are a few topics
we really want to chat with you about
today there are things you've talked
about publicly before so the first one
that I want to get into some of the
first talks I think I ever saw you give
or first things I saw you post about
publicly on the Internet related to the
insulin related hypothesis of obesity
and so I was hoping you could give us a
first of all before we get into
questions about it what exactly is this
insulin hypothesis for obesity and do
you think you could potentially recap
you're absolutely legendary debate with
dangerouslyhardcore.com Ida bait with
that I mean it was a really intense
debate you know that I had with with g4
so for those of you don't know this is a
2015 and and I was invited to speak at
the epic fitness summit in the UK and I
was required to debate John Keifer of I
don't know he had some carb backloading
thing I don't know and I mean I just
have to say I did such a good job in
that debate that he didn't even show up
before we even started oh that's how
good of a job I did so so there's always
a lot of Kiefer jokes that yeah but that
but honest to god he did not even show
up for the debate he his claim was that
he missed his flight
or and all the other flights were booked
or something like that so I was given
you know it's supposed to be like a
two-hour debate or hour-and-a-half
debate and I was given a full two hours
just to talk on insulin myself and that
that was actually that talk that kind of
launched my speaking career really
because I would it would just it went
really well so but yeah in that talk I
basically talked about the insulin
hypothesis which is just to kind of put
it in a nutshell it was kind of made
popular by Gary Taubes but really it's
been around for a while even in the days
of Adkins and stuff but um Gary Taubes
kind of the big guys think to really
push it with his good carbs or good
calories bad calories book and so the
idea is you know insulin is a hormone
that regulates blood sugar but it also
regulates fat metabolism and the idea is
well when insulin levels are high you
can't lose fat because insulin shuts
down fat burning and things like that
and while carbs are kind of the biggest
thing that supposedly helps stimulate
insulin release so if you eat a high
carb diet you will have a much harder
time losing body fat because your
insulin levels are high that that's
that's basically the whole hypothesis in
a nutshell there's some other nuances to
it but that's that's kind of what the
the hypothesis is supposed to be yeah
with that hypothesis what do you think
are the most notable major shortcoming
so that hypothesis so what someone comes
up to you and says I want to really
micromanage my insulin levels as a means
of improving my body composition what do
you tell somebody who who has that
stance how there's so many shortcomings
I think probably some of the biggest
ones are I would just say the biggest
one is look we have plenty of plenty of
studies now where I mean basically idea
is this I mean if it is all about
insulin that I should be able to take
two groups put one group of people on a
low-carb diet
another group on a high carb diet and
the group on the low carb diet should
lose more fat even if I keep calories
the same I mean that's basically what
should happen if the insulin hypothesis
is true there been a number of studies
that done that
none of them show any difference in fat
loss so that right there tells you
there's something wrong with the insulin
hypothesis and I can go into all kinds
of other problems with it you know
people focus on carbs but what people
don't understand is that protein also
stimulates insulin release and in fact
some types of protein particularly dairy
protein or whey protein actually can
stimulate more insulin release than
white bread can depending on how much
you're having so yeah I mean a lot of a
lot of people say that as if it's like a
technicality like well there are some
you know there can be some insulin
response to protein it's like no like
there there's like a robust insulin or
yes a lot of prep like it's big people
act like it's some kind of little fun
fact especially if it's animal protein
like branched chain amino acids are
essentially as insulin a genic as sugar
is oh yeah definitely like leucine
because I've had some people argue with
me that well the recent protein steam
weights insulin is because it's
converted to glucose first and then it's
the glucose thing writing insulin I'm
like no I mean there's there's plenty of
research showing leucine you know which
is a branched chain amino acid will
directly stimulate the pancreas to
produce insulin I mean so so protein
directly stimulates insulin release
there's no it's not due to it being
converted to glucose or anything like
that it directly stimulates insulin
secretion and like I said you know like
you said Eric it's actually a very
robust response there's one pretty good
study out there where they compared a
dairy protein to white bread and the
dairy protein actually created a more
robust insulin response than white bread
did you know so so this is just there's
just so many problems with the insulin
hypothesis it's just I mean in my talk I
went through I don't know at least
probably 15 different problems with the
insulin hypothesis I don't remember the
exact number but it's just it just falls
apart upon closer inspection so yeah for
anyone listening if you just google
James Krieger insulin or ecology insulin
he has like a 47 part series that's free
to read it's absolutely fantastic
so James one of the I guess like
rebuttals that people will will have to
this general general line of thinking
you know protein does stimulate a robust
insulin response but unlike you know
white bread or sugar or really any
carbohydrate source it also stimulates
glucagon response that's something that
you'll often see people bring up is that
actually like a complicating /
mitigating factor or is it just kind of
like a red herring or diversion like
that does that actually change the
picture one would expect to see in so
far as like how insulin would relate to
fat loss ya know it doesn't really
change the picture because what people
don't understand I mean I think people
automatically think that glucagon
completely opposes insulin in every
single way so they're assuming that
glucagon is gonna prevent insulins are
basically block insulins effects on fat
burning and stuff and there's human
studies showing that that's not true
glucagon does oppose insulin in terms of
glucose regulation but in terms of fat
metabolism it doesn't and so that that
argument kind of falls apart and and
really it makes sense why the body would
would release glucagon in response to
protein intake and really it's just to
keep blood sugar up because remember we
said that protein stimulates insulin
release if I just eat pure protein and I
get this insulin response my blood sugar
will drop I mean I mean if I don't have
any glucagon response my blood sugar
will drop so the reason your body
releases glucagon in addition to the
insulin is to stimulate your liver to
produce some more glucose to maintain
your blood sugar levels in the face of
that elevated insulin so that's why you
get a glucagon response with protein but
it has nothing to do it doesn't oppose
the effects on fat metabolism and in
fact I think there's three human studies
that looked at the effects of glucagon
on lipolysis which is the breakdown of
fat
in humans and all three of them found
that elevations of glucagon didn't have
any impact on that so so it's really it
is kind of just a red herring it doesn't
the increase in in glucagon doesn't
doesn't really mitigate the effect of
insulin in terms of actual body fat or
fat metabolism yeah I mean when I think
of the insulin hypothesis it really
stands out to me is one of those
instances where without question
understanding mechanisms is critically
important but sometimes we find
ourselves getting extremely caught up in
theory and mechanism and just ignoring
what's very apparently observable right
before our eyes so it's it's this thing
where you see a lot of people arguing
all these different biochemical pathways
and hormone regulation loops and it's
like yeah but but we put people on two
different diets and they did the same
thing yeah yeah and actually I guess but
you know I I was recently on on with
them
Eric Helms and Omar and we don't talk
about them we don't talk about them okay
so the people who shall not be named
brought up a really good point um you
know a lot of trainers I think make the
mistake of you know it's one thing to
say for example hey low-carb diets work
they help people lose weight that's
that's a factual statement they do they
are they work they can be very
beneficial for some people but as soon
as you start trying to claim all but the
reason the low-carb diets work is
because of insulin when you start
throwing out these mechanisms that
really don't have any good don't have
any solid data behind them that that's
where you run into problems because then
it leads you down all these other weird
pathways because if you start assuming
insulin hypothesis is correct and then
you have it creates all these crazy
diets like no carb diets and stuff like
that but because people are trying to
they're like oh I got to get my insulin
as well as possible so if a low carb is
good that means no carb is even better
you know and it just creates all these
crazy situations that or what happens if
someone's not losing weight and they
think oh I just I just got to drop my
carbs more you
they're dousing all their food in oil
and they're eatin actually more calories
and they're expending they think oh I
just got to get my insulin lower that's
the problem when you start putting in
correct mechanisms as to why a certain
diet works so so James I think to this
point you've you've probably mostly been
preaching to the choir like I think the
vast majority of our audience would be
totally on board with everything you've
said to this point but just based on
feedback we've gotten into previous
episodes I do know that there are some
keto advocates and and low-carb folks
who do listen to the podcast so just to
kind of I guess kind of extend an olive
branch it seems that people who are sold
on that way of eating do get really hung
up on the insulin mechanisms how insulin
can you know just totally shut down
lipolysis and theoretically fat burning
so you know maybe if they're confronted
with human trials they'll say oh if it's
outpatient people probably just weren't
adhering or if it's inpatient the trial
was just too short to really conclude
anything because they they do really
really like that mechanism so to kind of
keep things in the realm of mechanism
what are the mechanisms by which you
know eating more carbs and having maybe
slightly higher insulin or you know more
insulin spikes throughout the day what
are the mechanisms by which that doesn't
lead to inferior fat loss just you know
just so we have that mechanism talk for
the people who are really hung up on
that particular mechanism I think the
first thing I want to say is that what
we need to understand is insulin doesn't
operate in a vacuum so it's not like
only insulin is changing when you're
changing your macros and everything like
that there's other hormones that are
changing there's other factors there
there's even there's even things that
are changing in terms of the effects of
certain foods on like
the brain and food reward and appetite
regulation and things like that there
there's that I tried I made a point in a
blog post years ago that appetite
control and how much you eat and
everything is really complicated it's
actually there's I mean it's it's it's
the reason why let me put it this way if
it was really just about insulin then
you know it that the obesity problem
would be easy to solve because all we
would need to do is develop a drug which
there are drugs that do this that will
just basically block the effects of
insulin and boom you lose weight but the
the drugs that do exist that do that
don't work they don't really work and so
obviously it's not as simple as you know
just just changing insulin I mean
there's obviously other things going on
yes insulin is a regulator of fat
metabolism but also there's also other
hormones that are regulators of fat
metabolism like leptin for example in
fact I would argue leptin and it's a
more important regulator than insulin is
but and then there's just there's nerve
signals and III could go on and on and
on and I just I guess I want people to
appreciate just the complexity with
which how your body regulates body fat
levels and insulin just doesn't operate
on its own and so what can happen is
yeah you can still lose body fat on a
higher carb diet because yeah you know
let's say your insulin levels are higher
but we have to consider it's not like
those insulin levels stay elevated all
day long I mean unless you're
continuously eating 24 hours a day you
know you have fasting everybody has
fasting periods between meals and
everyone unless you have just like an IV
going into you when you go to bed
everyone has a fasting period at night
when they go to sleep so so what matters
is what's the net effect over you know
24 hours not not not what's happening it
you know in response to a single meal
what
what happens in response to a single
meal doesn't really matter it's it's
what's the overall net effect and and
even if you have somewhat higher insulin
levels to say during you know in the
time after a meal you still have this
big long fasting period you know at
night and between meals where insulin
levels come back down where you know the
effect on lipolysis isn't going to be
there so and then like I said with all
the other hormones going on and all the
other factors the net effect is you know
if energy intake is the same and
assuming protein intake is the same it
doesn't matter whether it's high carb or
high fat you're gonna lose the same
amount of body fat over a 24-hour period
it's just you know you know and what
people also remember is on a high carb
diet you know if I'm on a high carb diet
but I'm in an energy deficit so I'm
gonna you know I'm obviously eating less
calories that I'm expending what happens
is when I eat carbs those carbs because
I'm in an energy deficit those carbs
will either be burned for energy or
they'll get just stored as muscle
glycogen you know something like that
they're not going to suddenly you know
they're not gonna suddenly shut down my
ability to get rid of body fat you know
so I don't know if that answers your
question Gregg or or or answers I guess
the question maybe gives your you know
your your pro keto listeners a better
perspective on that if that's what
you're looking for but I guess that's
just what kind of comes to my mind so it
answers it well enough for me and if it
doesn't and if it doesn't answer it well
enough for them I'm sure the YouTube
comments will let me know I mean I mean
the other thing I just want to say on
that is what I want to reiterate there
is I'm not saying that low-carb is
doesn't work I think what some people
say is you know when you start arguing
against the insulin hypothesis or
something like that I think some people
take that as me as me or someone else
saying oh so you're saying that low-carb
doesn't work that it can't help me lose
body fat I'm like I'm not
saying that at all a the data is very
clear that low-carb can be a very
effective tool for a lot of people it's
just it's just a different it's just the
insulin is not the mechanism that's all
I mean that's really all I'm saying
I found myself arguing basically the
same point and it's that you know I'm
not saying that low-carb diets are bad
I'm just saying that insulin isn't what
makes them a useful strategy and
low-carb diets are not across-the-board
superior compared to a low-fat diet you
know and and that shouldn't be perceived
as a controversial statement because
there's I don't know decades and decades
and decades of evidence in support of
that oh well you just think of all the I
mean I think of all the 1980s
bodybuilders who were getting shredded
on super high carb diets and in fact
somebody made a post or maybe it was
even you Greg I don't know someone who
made a post that rule super high carb
diets are still kind of the norm at
least in the UK for a lot of
bodybuilders in contest prep you know
it's only seems like ammonia in North
America is where kind of the lower carb
way of trying to get shredded for
contests it kind of became the way to do
things but there's still plenty of
bodybuilders out there using really high
carb diets and they're getting super
super shredded lean for a contest you
know obviously it's not it doesn't seem
to be hurting them well I mean all of
those people are clearly blasting grams
and doing all of the DNP they can get
their hands on or for the glory they
attained from amateur natural
bodybuilding so I feel like that
somewhat negates that point but I I get
where you're coming from at least yeah
yeah James your sweet kid but you're
naive
alright so James you mentioned when
you're talking about insulin you know
that that body fat regulation is complex
and it's multifaceted and you also
touched on the idea of energy balance
being key and that's actually a great
transition to the next topic I wanted to
talk to you about so I've seen you write
and speak publicly about non-exercise
activity thermogenesis I guess my first
question
it's what got you so interested in
teaching people about meat yeah that's
such a great question so it's kind of
interesting the way it came about so is
actually when I was when I was the
research director for 2020 lifestyles
that Microsoft weight management program
I told you about earlier basically one
of the main facets of my job was to do
literature reviews for the doctors and
dietitians on staff and I would do these
literature reviews like twice a month
and a lot of times the CEO who was a
physician he would have questions for me
to be like oh I'd like you to look into
this or I'd like you to look into that
or whatever and one of the things that
came up because you know they did they
would do Grand Rounds with the clients
every Wednesday and so all the clients
that you know basically all the the
dieticians and the doctors would get
together and basically go over every
client in the program in like basically
an all-day meeting and one of the things
that often came up was you know you know
you'd get these people claiming they
weren't eating a whole lot and then but
they weren't losing weight and so the
CEO wanted me to kind of look into that
and stuff and so so I started to delve
into the literature and that's where I
you know basically got into all the
literature on underreporting but at the
same time that's where I actually
started to come across some of the
literature on eat and and and actually
what it was actually would also steam
like this was a lot of times if they had
a client who wasn't losing weight but
the client was swearing they were being
diet you know I'd hear n't to their diet
a lot of times they do a resting
metabolic rate test on him and these
clients would come out with you know
normal resting metabolic rate so so
obviously it wasn't an issue with
metabolism so um so I kind of just took
a dive into the literature and that's
where I kind of came across a summit
James Levine's work on meat or
non-exercise activity thermogenesis I
mean and then I started to look into the
data of how neat can go down with weight
loss
and also how neat can be an explanatory
variable for for the differences in
tendencies are people's tendencies to
gain weight and so that's kind of where
I start to really learn about neat and
and actually my first lecture that I
have ever did on NEET was to those
doctors and dietitians and really I
think Eric the the the lecture you saw
is really just an updated version of
that original lecture I did you know all
the way I mean this was back I don't
know 2007-2008 so so I've been yeah
talking about neat for for quite a long
time now so I would imagine for people
who aren't who don't already know a lot
about neat it's probably kind of a hard
sell to try to convince people that this
non-exercise activity actually makes a
meaningful impact in terms of their
overall daily energy expenditure can you
give the listeners an idea of a kind of
the relative impact or how much neat can
vary between people yeah and you know in
my talks I'll usually actually put the
number I'll put numbers up on it on the
screen so a perfect example is there's
data comparing people who sit and don't
really move bird versus people who sit
and fidget and the difference in energy
expenditure per hour for people who kind
of tend to fidget and you know while
they're sitting down I think I was
around a thirty calorie per hour
difference you might think oh well
thirty calories and that's not not very
much but imagine someone at an eight
hour per day desk job you know over
eight hours that person who fidgets a
lot is going to expend an extra 240
calories which is actually as much if
not more than some people expend in an
exercise session so and that's just
that's just like fidgeting and stuff the
difference is even greater versus from
standing still to standing and fidgeting
it's an even bigger difference and so I
used that to illustrate ok these numbers
add up over the day and then when you
start
looking at you know what I'd call free
living in energy expenditure because a
lot of these energy expenses are done in
people in a lab so they're kind of kind
of in a constrained environment but when
you then you have people out in the in
the world in their free living
environment these differences tend to
get even bigger so so yeah so that
that's what I do to kind of illustrate
the magnitude of the differences you can
see and in fact really cool study by
Eric Robison done in the night early
1980s they did a study where they had
they had people confined to a small room
so it's especially a small room that
would measure energy expenditure and you
couldn't really move around much in the
room it's you know I don't know the
exact size of the room but but it's like
it was like the size of a very small
office and they wanted to they'd have
people sit in this room and just do
their normal daily activities of daily
living in this room or whatever they
weren't doing any exercise and even and
there was a little couch in there and
they could watch TV and everything and
even when you confine people to the a
small room the energy expenditure
difference you could see between
different people was was pretty large in
fact I think it went up to something
like between the I think it went up to
something like a 700 calorie or so or
six six seven hundred calorie per day
difference between people which is I
mean that's that's a large difference
and again that's people confined to a
small room so you get people out in a
free living environment then those
differences get even bigger so I mean I
mean we're talking you know you know up
to a thousand calories or day or more in
terms of the impact neat can have in
terms on on your daily energy
expenditure it's it's actually it's
fairly substantial yeah and I mean that
that doesn't even account for jobs that
are particularly active you know yeah
that that's just putting a couple people
in a room but then when you factor in
the fact that somebody throughout the
day is essentially
wired to do a high-level app of activity
you could start to see discrepancies
between people get even larger but one
of the things about NEET that I find to
be so interesting is the differences
that we can see within people so you
mentioned previously that we we often
see that NEET goes down during weight
loss so I was wondering if you could
tell us two questions I hear a lot why
does NEET go down when we lose weight
and a slightly harder question how long
does that persist yeah so that that's
actually really good good question there
so um I think what I want to iterate
first is that energy expenditure is at
least partly biologically regulated so
your body actually tries to regulate its
energy expenditure not just through
adjustments in metabolism and things
like that but also an adjustments in how
much you move and and how much you
spontaneously move
you know because because we all have
spontaneous movement and what happens is
when you try to lose weight you know you
our bodies don't like to lose weight
they they don't like to be in an energy
deficit you know from an evolutionary
perspective it's bad to lose
weightweight because you know our
ancestors didn't know when they were
going to get their next meal so you want
to look you don't want to be losing
weight you want to hold on to your body
fat as much as you can so so when your
body senses that it's losing weight and
it's in an energy deficit it tries to
conserve calories and one of the ways
that does that is by basically
subconsciously impacting your movement
so you may fidget less you just may
spontaneously move around less and you
and you won't even really be aware of it
and it's just one of the body's
mechanisms to try to defend itself
against weight loss and there's I mean
there's it's there's a number of studies
that show that you know NEET definitely
goes down with weight loss so the second
part of your question what was that
again the second part of the question
the one that everybody wants to know is
how long does that persist you know it
is there a time where after weight loss
you basically
back to normal or or do you just assume
this this new reduced level of NEET
essentially in perpetuity yeah that's a
really good question and I would say
researchers don't really know if it
comes back or not I do know there's data
showing that even after a year of people
maintaining weight loss they're neat
levels were still down even after one
year so it does seem to persist now
again these were I think we'll
overweight and obese people so you know
it might be different with lean people I
don't know but it does seem to persist
for for quite a long period of time and
it may be one of the explanatory
variables as to why people have such a
hard time keeping weight off you know
you know after they lost it because most
people have successfully lost weight at
some point in their life at least people
who have been looking to lose weight but
most people have struggled to keep it
off and that that that's probably one of
the mechanisms as to why people have a
harder hard time keeping their weight
off is that like still depressed in
absolute terms or is it still depressed
in relative terms as well it's still
depressed in relative terms yeah the the
the paper in particular that I'm
thinking of is Rosenbaum I think they
published a paper in 2008 and libel
Rudolph
Rudy libel big big well-known metabolism
researcher they published a paper in
2008 the very paper I was talking about
where yeah they had people
they they had people lose 10 percent of
their body weight and then they had
people sustain that weight loss for
either eight weeks or I think it was
eight weeks or for up to a year and then
they looked at the relative energy
expenditure and they found that the
people who kept the weight off for even
a year their relative energy expenditure
was still below where you would predict
that it should be very interesting and
and I'm pretty sure it correct me if I'm
wrong but when they look at the there's
a big registry for people who have lost
weight and essentially kept it off and
activity level in general seems to
proceed to be a pretty key predictor of
successful weight maintenance is that
correct yeah that's actually there
there's actually a number of studies
showing that both both observational
data like you just mentioned Eric that's
the the National Weight Control Registry
and data from that suggests you know the
people who all right well for the
listener is the National Weight Control
Registry is basically a national
database of people who have lost at
least 30 pounds and kept it off for at
least a year and so people that sign up
for this database it gives researchers a
way to kind of look at the
characteristics of people who are
successful and one of the
characteristics is very high physical
activity levels and that's also been
shown in controlled trials so I there's
one that comes to mind I don't remember
the authors but they had people lose a
bunch of weight and then they assigned
him to two groups one group did like a
thousand calories per week and in terms
of physical activity energy expenditure
the other group did 2500 calories per
week and the group that did a thousand
calories per week gained most of their
weight back the group that did 2500
calories per week gained very little
back so so the data is very very quite
powerful to suggest that you know if
you're someone who wants to lose weight
and let's say you have lost weight
keeping high physical activity levels is
pretty critical to keeping it off over
the long term and you you recently
applied a fairly creative approach to
non exercise energy expenditure with one
of your clients which involve the use of
the use of a weighted vest do you mind
giving us a basically a brief
explanation of what the approach was and
how well it worked yeah so I had a
client Eric Lee Salazar who was
shooting to try to get his ifbb pro card
so he's a bodybuilding competitor and we
did an experiment where as he lost
weight we had him wear a weighted vest
to basically replace the weight that he
lost so I think he started at like I
think it's his initial body weight was
like 164 pounds I think and so as he
lost weight he added like a I think the
first weight of this was like 8 pounds
or something like that so so to keep his
external body weight at around 164 and
in fact he actually pushed it even a
little bit higher to where his external
weight his total external weight was
something like I don't know excuse me um
it was like maybe in the one around 180
or something like that but the idea
behind that was because as you lose
weight you had just you have less body
weight to carry around so you expend
less energy just in that sense so the
idea there was well one of the things to
help maintain his neat levels was to
basically make his body think that that
it hadn't lost any weight and so so he
was carrying around the same body weight
that he started with even though he had
lost a bunch of body fat and it actually
was a really successful experiment he
actually did get his bro card but what
was really surprising about it was not
only how well it worked for him but also
you know he had commented that is it was
his easiest contest prep he had ever
done it just made the whole process much
easier he he didn't have to do tons of
cardio
he didn't it actually even had an impact
on his appetite his appetite didn't go
up nearly as much as it typically would
in that type of situation so yeah it was
a really interesting experiment and it
was actually quite successful in yeah
I'd say one of the mechanisms is it
helped maintain his neat levels because
because he was he wasn't he had more he
wasn't carrying less body mass
so now I will say I think it that can
work really well for competitors who are
just trying to lose weight temporarily I
don't think it would work very well for
general population who are trying to
keep the weight off long term because
you would have to maintain the benefits
you'd have to wear the weighted apparel
indefinitely and most people aren't
gonna want to do that so well isn't
there a mouse study maybe two years ago
that took a similar approach but they
just like implanted metal weights in the
in the mices Mouse's mice at whatever in
their abdominal cavity yeah yeah
actually did I wrote an article for my
research review on that where I I
reviewed yeah it was really interesting
data were they yeah they took these
these rodents and they implanted weights
in their abdomen and the rodents just
lost spontaneously lost body fat and and
what the researchers determined it at it
actually didn't have anything to do with
the energy expenditure but it seemed
actually had an effect on appetite
regulation so as soon as they implanted
these weights into the abdomen and made
the rodents heavier the rodents started
to eat less so that they lost body fat
so then they returned to whatever their
normal weight was supposed to be you
know with obviously the addition of that
without weight and so the researchers
kind of speculated and that there it
needs to be more data on this but I do
think there's some merit to this because
just based on you know my clients
feedback the way he got there seems to
be another mechanism for regulation of
body weight that's in the bone so your
bones sense the loading and and what the
researchers said they did a bunch of
experiments to kind of you know tease
out the mechanism and and it appeared
that the bone the bone cells can sense
the loading and actually provide
feedback regulation to the brain in
terms of appetite so so that so the
bones of these rodents sense the
increased weight then that fed back on
the brains of the rodent say okay we're
too heavy here
you need to eat less and so these
rodents lost body fat because of it
because the bones were basically telling
the brain that that they were too heavy
so so yeah it's it's a really
interesting thing I think there there
needs to be more work on it I would love
to see some human stuff on it it's all
just rodent data at this point but but
yeah they they called it a gravitas stat
you know kind of like a thermostat you
know a thermostat regulates temperature
and they there seems to be a gravity
sensing mechanism in your body that
senses the load and senses how much body
weight you're carrying that may help or
that may actually act in terms of body
weight regulation so it's it's really
interesting stuff that's fascinating I
hope that they continue that line of
research because it'd be really
intriguing because obviously there are a
lot of different ways to load the
skeleton and be interesting to see how
different loading parameters affect that
response in terms of you know the
duration of loading or the the relative
intensity of loading I think there could
be some some really fascinating
implications for figuring out that
mechanism with a greater degree of
detail and by the way one detail we
haven't mentioned obviously Eric during
his prep had the weighted vest but he
also maintained a daily step count goal
is that correct yes he did 10,000 steps
a day and he maintained that throughout
his whole prep so the idea of wearing
additional weights in perpetuity is not
a very palatable option for the general
general population but do you think that
with the combination of step count goals
and physical activity goals that those
are kind of the key strategies that the
general population can use when they're
attempting to hopefully maintain their
weight loss once it's been achieved oh
yeah definitely I think you know step
count goals are actually great because
you know again when I talk about needs
for most people the biggest component of
neat daily need is just walking so so
the most efficient way to get your neat
levels up is just to walk around more
throughout your day and so I think step
counts are just a great great way for
people to do that
it's very low intensity it doesn't wear
you out it does it's not exhausting you
know anything like that you just
accumulate it through the day and and it
has a it has a really powerful effect on
on on body weight management in fact
I've had coaching clients who were
struggling and then I would just make
one change like getting their step
counts way up and all sudden they would
start to have some success so so I think
it's a really really great tool and I
think it tends to get underrated
sometimes I I think people focus too
much on on the exercise itself like
doing it you know whatever they're doing
in the gym or whatever cardio they're
doing and I don't think enough attention
gets paid to what's your cumulative
physical activity through the whole day
because that's really what I mean from a
fat loss perspective and I'm I'm
ignoring weight training as far as you
know the ability of weight training to
preserve muscle and everything like that
so ignoring putting that aside really
exercise from a fat loss perspective is
just a way to well I actually said
there's probably two things but but but
one of them is just a way to increase
total daily energy expenditure and so it
doesn't have to be high intensity it
doesn't have to be interval training or
something like that you know you can you
can accumulate you know large amounts of
very low intensity activity throughout
the day and it can work just as well and
in fact for for competitors and I've
seen Erick Helms make this comment which
I wholeheartedly agree with you know I
think competitors you know prepping for
contests tend to they tend to try to do
too much in terms of exercise they start
doing all this interval training and all
and and tons of cardio and stuff but the
thing is they're you're already in kind
of a depleted state you're already on a
super low-calorie diet and usually it
has kind of adverse effects it's way
better in those situations just to
accumulate way more I think low
intensity activity because it's not
exhausting and it's just it's just much
easier to accumulate so so I so I think
it's really effective both for general
population and competitor
perfect now James before we move on I do
want to mention we have a three-strike
rule if you bring up Erik Helms a third
time okay we will end the recording all
right so I got a question for you we've
talked a lot about weight loss and
obviously when we talk about working
with clients weight loss often comes
with some kind of goal in mind a lot of
times people will have a specific body
fat in mind an actual number a body fat
percentage that they're shooting for and
I've seen you you've got a series of
articles on your website about body copy
body composition measurement very very
thorough well-written articles
what when a client tells you they want
to get their body fat percentage tested
how do you respond to that the first
thing I just say I I discourage them
from doing it I just say I say it's way
too inaccurate I said I just tell them
the number you get has is there's just a
huge amount of error in it it's not
going to tell you anything that that you
can't already that basically you can't
already get in terms of other tools so
you know I encourage people who are
trying to lose weight just use a
combination of body weight and
circumference measurements and maybe you
know like how your clothes fit things
like that that will tell you everything
you need to know you don't need a body
fat percentage to tell you whether
you're losing fat because it's too
inaccurate anyway and in fact I've had
situations where people have clearly
lost body fat their measurements have
gone down their clothes fit better and
yet a body fat device like BIA will tell
them that they've actually gained body
fat and that's just it's just not a you
it's just not useful like there's you
know it it's just not a useful tool for
for the vast majority of people now you
mentioned BIA which is single frequency
BIA is a garbage method it is I tell my
clients if we're going to use single
frequency BIA
that's fine as long as I never ever hear
about it the entire time we're working
together because I'm not going to be
held accountable for that random number
generator but what what do you think are
the best methods for individual use if a
person insists that they they really
want to get it tested well if someone
wants to get it tested you know if
you're just trying to track progress
over time I would say skin folds are
probably the best but don't worry about
what the number says the number is
meaningless like you know whatever the
body fat percentage basically just are
your skin folds going down over time now
I'm assuming they're being measured
correctly and everything and that's kind
of a you know assuming they're being
measured correctly and things like that
if your skin folds are going down over
time and to in terms of the millimeter
measurements you're losing body fat so
but if someone insists on they want to
get a body fat percentage I tend to
gravitate I would gravitate towards
either hydrostatic weighing which is
basically underwater weighing or DEXA
but I will still reiterate that even
dexa and hydrostatic weighing can have
pretty significant error rates so but
those are the ones that I would tend you
know if someone insisted on doing it and
they want a number
I would those are the two techniques I
would probably lean towards saying that
they should do you know something you
rarely hear talked about with
hydrostatic wing is the general
unpleasant nature of testing I feel like
people drastically underestimate how not
fun it is as the person being tested you
basically like if you have anything
resembling a phobia of drowning under
water weighing or hydrostatic weighing
is not for you you basically have to
expel every last bit of air in your
lungs while submerged and to get a good
number typically they'll have you do it
a solid 15 or 20 times now you did
mention DEXA now just to give people an
idea without getting into convoluted
specific statistic
if someone if your client came to you
and said James I got my body fat tested
using DEXA and the decks have put me at
14 percent body fat when they say that
to you what is the range in your head if
like okay here's what their body fat
realistically might be if the DEXA gave
them 14 yeah it can actually be fairly
large I would say probably for most
people it's going to be privately plus
or minus five or six points but there
are some studies that can suggest even
up to you know eight nine or ten point
differences so you know that person that
came to me with 14 in in my head I'm
thinking well geez they could be as low
as 8 or 9 or they could be as high as 20
I mean it's a it's a fairly broad broad
range and now now that now it's gonna
vary from one per some people yeah they
may be fairly close to 14 other people
it may be way off
but the problem is there's really no way
of knowing who's way off and who isn't
I can I can just say statistically
chances are there's going to be a
there's a there's a potentially fairly
broad range there so which which is why
it's not useful I mean that's such a big
range you know eight percent that's
that's you know that's like that's
pretty lean that's that's like basically
men's physique contests lean versus
twenty percent which is way off of
contest shape I mean that's you know
that's where you're carrying a fair
amount of body fat I mean your range
there basically describes the entire
duration of a prep from yellin to finish
so it's like hey we can tell you that
you're somewhere in the process of your
heaviest and your lightest well I mean I
I think the object lesson that at least
helped a lot of people a few years ago
even though I don't see this referenced
as much anymore is one of those times
that Alberto Nunez just got [ __ ]
diced like just shredded to the bone
he wouldn't got a DEXA in
that shape and I want to say it said he
was like 9.6% which you know somewhere
around 10% is certainly lean but it's
not
Alberto Nunez onstage lean and and I
think that you know just because
Alberto's so well-known and people kind
of know what 10% is supposed to look
like and they can juxtapose that number
with how Alberto looked at the end of
that prep I think that helped kind of a
mini generation of people realize that
like oh DEXA isn't perfect but I I think
at this point that was probably five or
six years ago so I don't think those
pictures are as well-known anymore that
would probably be worth putting in the
show notes oh yeah definitely definitely
yeah it's it's funny we had a there have
been times were in the lab I would
measure somebody using the same exact on
the same day same pre-visit guidelines
you know all the measurements taking
place within 60 90 minutes and we would
measure them on several different you
know using several different devices bod
pod pod exa BIA a whole bunch of
different body comp tests and they might
get a range of values that covered a you
know one one device put them at twenty
the other put them at twenty nine
percent literally at the same time under
the same conditions and after getting
these like four or five different
numbers they'd say okay so what is my
what's my actual body fat and I would
just look at and be like I don't know it
probably between twenty and twenty nine
plus or minus a few percentage points in
either directions so 17 to 32 like who
knows that they're like well you're
supposed to give me the damn answer and
I'm like usually when you go in for body
comp testing you walk out with more
questions than answers and if you want a
really precise number just donate your
body to science and hope that you have a
way of figuring it out in the afterlife
is the only way to actually measure it
and not estimated is to you know
completely break down a body melted
just see what the fat content was which
isn't very practical yeah yeah a and
Eric what you were talking about here it
actually reminds me there's an article
on my website called cheat your body fat
test where I described the various ways
that you can change your body fat
percentage that day of a test like like
there's there are all kinds of tricks
you can do to manipulate the body fat
percentage that you get from that device
which just shows you how how inaccurate
it can be if you can if you can cheat it
that easily definitely now James you
mentioned in your in your introduction
one of the ways a lot of people know
about use through your contributions to
the research in in sport nutrition and
exercise science you have an incredible
skill set as it pertains to statistics
so branching out from our discussion of
measurement and now into research as a
whole you know you have your research
review you do research yourself when you
look at the evidence-based fitness kind
of field of research so we're talking
exercise science with with some sport
nutrition mixed in what do you think is
the biggest area requiring improvement
in our field I still I think I think on
the training side there's still so much
that we can learn and I think the reason
is is because because there are so many
different ways you can design training
programs and and because of the even the
challenges you have with measurement
techniques you know ultra ultra sound
versus MRI for muscle mass or body comp
techniques or whatever there's just a
lot we don't know you know I'm the
nutrition side of things you know and
I've said this in the past you know
there's there's really nothing
groundbreaking in terms of nutrition you
know there's some interesting things
that come out every now and then but
overall from a nutrition perspective we
pretty much have a good idea of what
nutrition you need whether it is your
whether you're trying to maximize muscle
or whether you're
whose body fat or whatever did you know
I would say in the next 10 years you're
not gonna see anything radically new in
those along those lines now from a
training perspective I think there's
just a lot of still interesting stuff
that that can be done just because of
the hundreds and hundreds of ways you
can design a training program which
makes it hard to do research on training
because you can't you can't study every
permutation you have you can have of
training programs yes so you have to try
to isolate a single variable and even
when you do that when you isolate that
variable it still is is kind of confined
to the context of that study and I'll
just use one example was the volume
study that I worked on with Brad
Schoenfeld the one that you know this
one individual in the fitness industry
basically got all pissy about and
everything he you know we did that study
because we were just curious like okay
like you know is there we just wanted to
see is there a is there you know is
there some upper level ceiling to volume
or whatever and and so the subjects in
this study actually at the highest level
volume did quite a bit quite a high
level of volume in terms of weekly sets
I mean I think it was for quadriceps you
know if you count all the compound
movements and and isolation movements on
quadriceps I think it was up to like 45
weekly sets which is pretty pretty high
and what we found is that basically if
you look at the pattern of results and
it wasn't all statistically significant
but it but but the overall pattern
showed that the more volume you did the
better results you got and at the time
we I thought well you know maybe this
suggests maybe that you know the upper
ceiling two volumes maybe higher than we
thought but that's still very contextual
in the sense it's contextual in the way
the study that was designed so you know
the study was
they did the subjects did a whole body
workouts with fairly short rest
intervals 90 second rest they were doing
squats and leg press and I mean if
you're doing a whole body workouts with
that short arrest that that's pretty
exhausting and so the caveat there is
yeah
maybe there's a volume effect there and
right maybe it's only in the context of
the way the training program was
designed if you're doing whole body
workouts with short rest intervals you
know three days a week because if you
look at other studies that have used
split routines were with longer rest
periods they don't necessarily show the
same thing that we showed and again
there were some people that tried to
argue that that we were trying to
manipulate our data and everything to
try to get what we wanted which was one
of the [ __ ] dumbest things I've ever
heard I mean it's like but it has
nothing to do with that it's just that
you know there's such a variety of ways
to design a training program I mean our
results were very similar to another
study on on I think it was like Britta
or Brazilian naval cadets who found
pretty much the exact same thing we did
it's just that those subjects weren't
what weren't they were kind of untrained
subjects but they had a similar study
design it was whole body workouts
relatively short rest intervals three
days per week but again if you look at
the studies where they use split
routines and different different
training program designs they don't
necessarily show what we showed and I
think what that does is it shows you
that there's a context that you have to
you have to take all the variables into
play how was the training program
designed you know what what exercises
were used what rest intervals were used
and and you know you can't
one study can't really tell you
everything you know it just it's like a
very small piece of an overall puzzle
and that's actually why I find the
training research kind of fascinating
because it's a it's a puzzle where we
have very few pieces and so there's a
lot of there's the kind of a lot of
speculation and and it's interesting as
we get more puzzle pieces to kind of see
where things go but
I mean you're never research is never
gonna tell you how to train because
there's just too many permutations I
mean I think that the best research can
kind of give you kind of very rough
guidelines and I think that's the best
it's gonna do I think some people make
the mistake of thinking this study tells
me exactly what how I need to train I I
need to do this and that that's not
that's not how training research work
works especially when we consider a lot
of these studies have very small numbers
of subjects I mean we're talking you
know 10 people per group and everything
and that's really just given that people
vary so much and how they respond to
training programs that's really not
enough people to be able to really have
any anything even resembling a
definitive conclusion you know it's all
we can say is well things kind of look
like this you know maybe it suggests
this you know just so there's a lot of
caveats and nuance and everything to to
it out there so so I guess yeah that's
kind of my long-winded answer to your
your question about that so it sounds
like on the sport nutrition side you're
like yeah whatever we got it but on the
training side the area for improvement
you'd like to see is more data but also
seeing more ways to isolate some of
these training variables and see how
they affect these programs and obviously
the challenge there is in many cases
when you tweak one variable you
inadvertently tweak others in the
process but more directly I'd like to
hear what do you think is the biggest
area requiring improvement in our field
specifically as it pertains to
statistics I think the big thing is is I
think people way to make a lot of
mistakes as far as like what are P
values and what they mean and everything
like that you know people I think
misunderstand statistical significance
what I wish people can understand is
that you know it's not statistics you
know and data aren't black and white
it's really more telling you it's all
just
abilities and kind of gives you an idea
of which way things kind of lean and and
gives you an idea of the strength of the
evidence but it doesn't it's not you
know for example just because something
is statistically significant doesn't
mean there's a real effect there and
likewise just because something is not
statistically significant it doesn't
mean there's no effect there it's really
more trying to I wish people can
understand I think people struggle with
the nuance of it all and how you know
it's not black or white there's there's
like all kinds of shades of grey and but
you can take the same two people can
take the same study with the same
statistics and actually interpret the
data differently and neither one of them
are really wrong and either person is
really wrong it's just it's just a
matter of interpretation
maleeh just - trying to interpret very
incomplete data and you know it's III I
think the biggest thing I think people
need to take away from statistics is
statistics are just a tool to kind of
give you an idea of which way things are
leaning in terms of probability yet this
is it's probably this and in some cases
you can say with stronger evidence okay
that it kind of helps weigh the strength
of the evidence
okay well this study the statistics say
yeah this is this is pretty good
another study says oh well it's only
nning this way but we can't you know
it's it's not very strong I would love
to see and there's a push for this in
the overall literature at least in the
in the non exercise literature to kind
of move away from my p-values and things
like that to more more subjective
interpretations of evidence and and and
maybe gradations of evidence so like how
strong the evidence is and even there
it's like
it's just such a subjective world I mean
it's like like I said I mean you can
have two really smart people look at the
exact same data and the same statistics
and actually have slightly different
conclusions and they both and you really
can't say which person is wrong because
it's incomplete data in the first place
so so I don't know if that answers your
question
I just I think people should understand
that there's just there's so much gray
area when it comes to scientific
evidence and statistics and everything
you know there's no there's there's
really no hard and fast answers on
things yeah I mean the more I talk to
people that do statistics and do their
statistics thoughtfully the more I hear
people reiterate some of those same
points of like we the more you do stats
and again do them thoughtfully not just
kind of follow a checklist and go
through it you start to develop an
appreciation for like these aren't black
and white complete rules we're talking
about different strategies and so like
an example you mentioned to people can
look at the same results done the same
way and have different interpretations
but if you give to different people the
same data set they might yield different
actual outcomes no there-there was a
really really cool study looking at that
oh maybe three or four years ago or so
where what they did is they took a big
data set looking and basically it was
looking at like penalties like fouls in
football or soccer for our american
listeners and basically they they gave
this dataset to a bunch of different
research groups like 30 or 40 different
research groups or like statisticians
and basically said hey we want to know
if players of color are more likely to
get carded for similar infractions when
compared to white players and you know
basically gave them the data set and
said you analyze this whichever way you
think is best and most appropriate
and what they came up with was responses
ranging all the way from I want to say
like a non significant effect in favor
of white players actually getting carded
more often all the way to really really
huge effects showing players of color
getting carded more often and literally
everything in between just based on
different choices for model selection
and what covariates to take into account
and whatnot and and that was I think a
really cool study that you know just
illustrates the degree to which
assumptions and decisions made prior to
data analysis or unfortunately more
realistically probably during data
analysis can can really impact what sort
of results you wind up with and this is
my own personal hobbyhorse this is one
of the reasons why I think that it needs
to become much more common practice for
researchers to share their primary data
set because the way that they chose to
analyze it very well may be a completely
appropriate way to do it but it's
probably not the only way to do it and
if the data is there and available for
other people to dig into you know if you
don't agree with the way the researchers
analyzed it you can just reanalyze it
yourself yeah I totally agree with you
Greg on that I like the idea of datas
more data sets becoming publicly
available and everything you know and I
also think I would love to see the
exercise science community do more like
pre-registration of trials things like
that where they kind of outline their
data sets or outlined what they're gonna
do ahead of time not that that prevents
you know any type of invasion or
anything like that but at least you know
you know it forces me it always gives an
idea that people are planning ahead of
what they're gonna do and not not
deciding after the fact I a perfect
example Greg of actually what you just
talked about in terms of publicly
available data so there was that that
low-carb study that came out from
David Ludwig and his group recently
where they showed that these little car
people had had a better energy
expenditure during weight maintenance
but you know the data sets publicly
available and Kevin Hall went back
through the data and basically analyzed
it and basically showed well that's
showed that the data wasn't you know the
the conclusions that David all the way
to come to came to wasn't really
supported by the data and then even I
did some of my own analysis of the data
because I'm one of these people I think
you know if the data fit if the data is
fairly robust towards a certain
conclusion then it should be fairly
robust towards the type of analyses you
do but if if I do different statistical
analyses and I get quite a bit different
answers and then that tells me the data
is probably not very robust in terms of
whatever conclusion was made and that's
actually what I found even with the
Ludwig data I ran some analyses on it
that were different from what Kevin Hall
did and and I I didn't come up with you
know similar conclusions
you know Bayes and I was doing analyses
that were you know perfectly appropriate
for the data just like you know I would
say David a lot of Whigs analyses were
appropriate but it just it wasn't robust
to you know violations of assumptions or
you know or other factors in the data so
so yeah I would say I think there needs
to be more you know publicly available
data and that gets back to your point of
view ecstatic but you know it always
kills me when people interpret it that
way and saying no the p-value was less
than 0.05 so we know this worked and
you're like yeah but if they chose a
slightly different post hoc test that
p-value becomes point oh seven and now
it completely turns everything we know
about the world upside down that doesn't
seem like a very sensible way to
approach this stuff you know what I mean
no I and people love to have like
thresholds and categories and stuff and
the world again that the world of
science doesn't really work that way
it's not like there's some dividing line
that makes something a true result
versus not a true result it's all um
it's all just kind of a shade of gray
and and basically making statements
about okay well the evidence favors this
how much does it favor it by you know by
this much or whatever you know I mean
that that's really what what it comes
down to I mean it's kind of like the
weatherman right so the weatherman he
makes predictions on the weather and he
doesn't tell you okay it's gonna rain or
it's not gonna rain he tells you okay
well we've got maybe an 80% chance of
rain so if it doesn't rain that doesn't
mean the weatherman was wrong I mean it
was still realm of probability that it
wasn't gonna rain you know I even saw
people make this you know I'm again I'm
a big stat fan and I love the website
538 I think nate silver does a really
good job on in terms of statistical
analysis of various things from sports
to politics and and stuff like that and
of course you know during the the 2016
election
you know his analysis favored that
Hillary Clinton would win and I think in
the in the one or two days before the
election
basically he he had given Hillary
Clinton I think basically like a two out
of three chance of winning well of
course
Donald Trump won the election and so
then everyone started piling on me
silver saying or or whenever I would
actually you know quote Nate silver on
things they'd be like well but he
clearly got the election wrong but he
didn't get the election wrong in fact if
you look at it he gave Donald Trump the
best probability of winning out of any
other you know political analysts
analytic website you know a one out of
three chance is still a reasonable
chance to win you know so I think people
need to you know I think people struggle
when they that when they try to think in
terms of probabilities it's not it's not
you know again it's not a sure thing
you know to really understand
probabilities like you'd have to rerun
that same election to know whether nate
silver was truly wrong or not you'd have
to run that same election you know like
a hundred times
and if nate silver was right well Donald
Trump will win 33 out of a hundred times
and Hillary Clinton would have one you
know the other 66 or 67 times so that's
how probabilities work you know yeah and
that you know back to your example about
the weather you know the the weather
forecaster is gonna tell you an 80%
chance of rain they're also probably
gonna tell you whether you know it might
be an all-day drizzle or you need to
start putting boards across your windows
and maybe get to higher ground right
they're gonna tell you some estimate of
a magnitude and some estimate of a
probability and and I'm with you I think
the more that we start viewing
statistics that way
the better for the field now a follow-up
question on this podcast we don't get
shy about talking about stats as you're
obviously aware now every now and then
we predict where we see things going in
the future in terms of how the field
uses statistics so in the past we've
talked about you know more sharing of
data or open access data we've talked
about maybe multicenter trials for
different exercise interventions we've
also talked about you know shifting
toward other types of analyses you know
using more Bayesian methods potentially
using more linear mixed models that
incorporate random effects where do you
see things going specifically as it
pertains to statistics in the field yeah
I would actually kind of gris with it in
fact before you mention the Bayesian
analyses I that was one thing that
popped in my head when you were kind of
answer asking the question I would like
to see things go more in that direction
or at least just get away from these
hard you know at least get away from
these you know statistically significant
versus non significant and instead you
know what just report a p-value you know
and let the researchers decide
you know how to interpret that data
rather than having these these cutoff
points and these and turning things into
categories and things like that I'm a
big fan of just just report your data
you know talk how you interpret it and
let other people and you know if they're
gonna interpret it differently they're
gonna interpret differently III really I
would also like to see the field just do
more complete reporting of data and you
are starting to see that some more you
know you're seeing more journal articles
with supplementary materials things like
that because because I you know I can't
tell you how many times I've gotten
frustrated where I'll be reading a paper
and I'll be like why didn't they report
you know like like why didn't they
report confidence intervals in this
study or why didn't they you know or or
stays where they didn't report the
p-values at all they'll just say well P
was greater than 0.05 I'll be like well
what if it was 0.06 like like you know I
just I want to see more transparency and
just complete reporting of datasets and
and yeah I move towards less binary type
statistical decision-making and more
more finding ways to basically grade the
strength of evidence versus versus you
know like I said the strength of
evidence versus binary decisions yeah
don't you love that when they say well
the p-value is over 0.05 and you're like
yeah you had seven people in the group
of course it was give me the damn actual
information so James this is the
question we asked a lot of our guests
obviously you you train and you coach
others as well as a coach do you use any
strategies that lack scientific
substantiation or even some strategies
that maybe go against the grain when it
comes to the current consensus in the
evidence-based fitness community oh yeah
I do I mean because again it's like I
talked about earlier the research can't
cover everything in terms of training so
so so there are things that you do that
maybe may be kind of speculative maybe
you know maybe there's a little bit
about
it's out there but nothing really strong
you know things like you know something
I like to do with my own training or
some of my clients training is I like to
kind of cycle volume approaches so I
like to kind of progress from a lower
volume the higher volume until they kind
of plateau in progress and then maybe
back their volume off again and start
again you know I will say there's not
it's there's really no research to
suggest that that approach is better
than others you know there's some I
would say theoretical reasons why it
might be good but you know that's this
mainly speculation on my part it's not
you know I'm just doing some things that
you know I think there's probably a
reasonable there's there's a sound
there's a sound reasoning behind it it
could be inaccurate you know maybe some
studies will come out show them that I'm
completely wasting my time doing it that
way
and that's fine I'm totally open to
being wrong but yeah I mean I yeah I'm
an evidence-based guy but I do things
that you know don't have a solid basis
in evidence because if I tried to do
everything that had a solid basis of
evidence I don't even know how to design
training programs because there's no
like I said studies can't tell you
everything right and you also have a
secret insulin suppression strategy to
help promote fat-burning is that right
what you weren't supposed to talk about
that on this pot oh yeah yeah
your clients told me that you were just
throwing people off the scent so you
could keep that I keep that as your your
main drawing point for clients no I mean
what one of the things that I always
like to say is like if someone doesn't
know anything about research and is not
at all conversant in the literature I
tend to be somewhat skeptical of what
they have to say like I'm not gonna
dismiss it outright but it does make me
more skeptical I also get skeptical if
someone purports to have citations for
literally everything they do when they
train clients because then it's like
well I mean it at what point is your
experience as a practitioner coming into
play here like how could you possibly
rely on research for every decision you
make when coaching
humans so yeah yeah I think I think it
is all about kind of striking striking
that balance and you know just figuring
it out like what what's most appropriate
for for you and your clients yeah you
don't want to be getting your your
clients training program straight from
the table in a research study cuz that
is a plain ass boring ass training
program right what are you talking about
I put all my clients on the Schoenfeld a
high-volume protocol exactly well there
is at least one person out there who
would very much like you to videotape
one of your clients go through the
protocol as I understand it there's a
bounty on it or something like that
oh really I don't know probably I I
checked out of that drama in like
January of this I'd oh I have no idea
what the current developments are I know
I checked out of a long time too so it's
funny I still hear little things through
the grapevine every now and then you
know people will say oh did you hear
this I'm like no I don't know I don't
even I don't even pay attention to it
anymore so James if you didn't want to
deal with bounties on a regular basis I
don't know why you would get into the
fitness industry is a very serious
business
all right well James ease we've taken up
a bunch of your time and we we sincerely
appreciate it for our listeners who
would like to to stay in touch with you
or stay up to date with your work where
can people find you online oh yeah you
can just go to my website weight ology
net I've got a bunch of articles on
there actually some of the articles we
talked about my insulin series my body
comp series you know it's free for
everybody on there and yeah and then I
have my research review and then I also
got you know coaching and all that other
stuff so so yeah we told you net and
also all my social media accounts are on
there so if people want to follow me
they can use those as well perfect well
James was great talking with you hope to
see again sometime soon I'm sure we'll
run into you at a fitness conference in
the near future but until then
thanks for joining us take care and
we'll talk to you later yeah guys thanks
for having me thanks for listening to
the stronger by science podcast now Greg
and I are not experts in medicine or
health or really anything else for that
matter so before you make any changes to
your diet and exercise habits make sure
you check with a doctor or another
healthcare professional if you enjoyed
this podcast and you'd like to support
it
visit stronger by science com to check
out the products and services that we
offer thanks for listening and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]